i do chairman
thank you very much
indeed we are getting some feedback i
think one of the telly's has a volume on
just bear with us please members of the
public we do have
a bit of a technical glitch
is that better
i don't think speaking up is going to
help us just think it's going to make it
worse
just apologies for this everybody just
bear with us just a moment while we sort
the
okay we're back on um
okay
that's gonna slightly throw me but i
think we're okay so we've um we've done
our introduction so let's get on with
the meeting proper shall we um first of
all could we please have apologies for
absent
we have apologies from councillors
kendall curtis hentra seraphin and
jennings
thank you very much could we have any um
declarations of interest or disclosures
please councillor crump first of all
thank you mr chairman um i'm the award
member for application number
2101274 the welfare center cravenline
and i've registered to speak on that so
i will be withdrawing from the debate
thank you very much cancer mills
sorry thanks mr chairman um the
uh
application for windmill farm um
foxhill i i'm a customer of this
company so i just declare that if it
weren't i'll come with it open mind on
that and also on the
gosh you can't see the um footpath
uh i did speak with one of the residents
there to get direction to where this
footpath is
and uh but again i come with an open
mind on it thank you marvelous thank you
very much councillor fleming
again on
uh
a fairly regular customer in that
particular business but it doesn't
affect how i feel about this
lovely thank you very much i will also
make the same one my wife has a horse
and we've shopped there a couple of
times but i'm here with an open mind so
any other declarations of interest
anyone wants to make at this point
no marvelous in that case let's get in
to all the applications our first
application is application number
2101274 ful that's welfare center craven
lane in southam and our presenting
officer is joe brook joe over to you
thank you chair
the application site is located when the
physical confines are so firm as
indicated by the black dot for you
the application site currently contains
a billet hut which is lawful usage for a
community hall
furthermore the hut was listed as a
community asset on the 25th december
2013. however the listing expired on the
19th of december 2018 and the hut has
been redundant for a number of years
all of which is set on the officers
report
the application is also started within
the conservation area as well as close
proximity to the grade two listed craven
arms hotel so just for clarity
this is the craven arms hotel under
associated list of buildings because
they're by virtue of being attached and
this is the parent of the conservation
area so you can see the application site
is contained within the conservation
area
this is the existing hook um as the
plans indicate on the site of the minute
the application itself is proposing
removal of the hut which i've just shown
and the development of a free bedroom
dwelling as indicated before you the
dwelling would be set 8.7 meters to
ridge with two front-facing dormers
torment windows rear garden area and two
parking spaces
so this is a site plan
which indicates the rear immunity space
and the two parking spaces to the side
tandem parking spaces or what i like
that's where the drone will be fronted
in location and that's craven lane
itself
the surrounding street scene is defined
by a number of different scales masses
and heights and easy to the east of the
site is a three-story block of
apartments craven court
however the dwayne has then stepped down
and hiked to two-story all the way down
to penndot street
directly jason and billet hut is a
one-half story dwelling we have a row of
single-story shops and a large two-story
dwelling facing on to penndot street
which is taller than enabling properties
on craven lane
to the rear of the site is a private car
park and a number of three-story
apartments the broader predominantly
this shows
sorry joe it looks like we're having
further technical difficulties could you
grab a microphone off one of our other
um
one and spare ones thank you very much
it's going so smoothly isn't it yeah
thank you cancer
so i'll sort of restart it quickly the
surrounding street scene is defining by
a number of different scales and masses
and heights immediately so the size of
three-story block of apartments which is
known as craven court however the
dwellings then stepped down in height to
two stories all the way down to pendle
street directly adjacent to billet hut
is the one half story dwelling where a
row of single-story shops and then a
large two-story dwelling face
non-dependent street which is taller
than the naming properties on craven
lane
to the rear of the site is a private car
park a number of three-story apartments
and the predominant materials are red
brick grey roof slating an additional
white render
so this is the plumber for you is how it
fits along craven lane and you can see
within the street seeing the different
sizes and scales masses of properties so
craven caught three-story apartments
to the rear further apartments so in the
car park area just beyond and then alex
steps down two stories along craven lane
i will show some photos as well
so here we go this is the existing
billet hut which is proposed to be
demolished neighboring properties and
the stepped phone sort of thing going
along craven line all the way to pandora
street
i'll see just give you as professive of
the um site itself for the car park area
but i'll show you some more
so this take from google earth just
simply gives the best perspective of the
street scene the one half story in
the shops and stepped down all the way
down to penndot street itself and
there's a hot site that's up there
facing upwards three-story apartments
this is the listed building but these
are listed by virtue of being attached
also that then sweeps around and this is
all within the conservation area
and then you've got the apartments
just the sites just in there with the
car parking area
so this goes into the car parking area
onto the right
and then you can see the apartments to
the rear as well as some very large
dwellings
and that's the end of the presentation
as sat on the officers report and on
planning balance the application is
considered to comply
with the aries development plan and all
policies contained there in and that's
searched offstring recommendations for
approval there are no updates thank you
chair joe thank you very much indeed we
will move to our first speaker of the
evening who is councillor angela john
from southern town council
council john welcome good evening
please make your way forward
that was that was beautifully delivered
however i am going to ask if you don't
mind if you could take a seat we do need
to have microphone on so that it can be
recorded um you you technically have
three minutes um but clearly you don't
need that so whenever you're ready if
you want to press the button and say
what you said
marvelous thank you very much indeed
okay we'll move to our second speaker of
the evening who is mr alan wright
mr rights good evening and welcome
please do come forward and grab a seat
either desk is good
and you also have three minutes
um
i will give you a 30 second warning for
your time is up otherwise whenever
you're ready do feel free to start
all right thank you very much um i live
at 11 graven lane which is chica biddy
cottage
and it is the 1.5 story building
that mr brook showed earlier
with this with the skylights in the roof
now with having the building built
opposite
with the normal windows
people will look down and straight into
my skylights
straight onto my bed so i'm not
objecting to the
something being done with the hood
i'm not objecting to something being
built
what i am objecting to is the height
on the basis as it said in the comments
we could say that it was overbearing
i think something that is nearly twice
the size of your house and is only it's
a one-way street so it is only about 20
feet away from me
i think that is overbearing
it is also
affecting my right of light
and
i think it's infringing on my privacy
because it's overlooking into my windows
i've also been asked by mrs minnie who
lives at number one which is the other
side of the uh welfare center
to say that she is in support and she
has lived there 55 years
next to a one-story building
now
the proposal is that it's three nearly
three stories
so
all in all that is our objection to it
on that basis
the other point is that i spoke to mr
brooke and he referred to the apartments
that are further up the road
the difference is
they have windows that face across
craven lane just the same
but on the other side of the road there
are no windows
so it doesn't oh it doesn't overlook any
windows at all it looks onto brick walls
and roofs
whereas this will look straight onto my
windows straight under my skylights
and again infringe on my privacy my
right to light and i think it's
overbearing
i think it's out of character with the
other there are only four houses
in the street
and i think this should be built
in line with the other with the other
four
simply a
maximum a two-story building
i mean ideally as a lot of people have
said oh they're gonna knock it down and
build some book the bungalow
because a bungalow would have been ideal
there
the amenities there's the doctors 30
seconds sorry 30 seconds there's this
chemist there's local facilities
but i think to have windows and there's
a tree there's a tree next door to the
welfare center if somebody climbed that
and looked through my skylights i could
call the police but if somebody puts
windows in a plan for a new house
what's the difference
thank you very much
thank you very much before you go
anywhere members do you have any
questions for mr rights please
no
okay um i should have asked this earlier
and forgive me for this that we
obviously remember your members of the
public you'll see on both desks we have
some wipes and some antibacterial hand
wipes once you've finished speaking if
you don't mind just giving the desk a
quick wipe down and one on the speaker
on the microphone as well that'd be
really appreciated and there is a bin
just between the desks
that's right thank you very much thank
you
okay we'll move to our next speaker um
who is uh grinder
darling while i think that's pronounced
correct please tell me i have i
apologize if i haven't
i gave it a go so
marvelous um welcome good evening this
is our applicant you you have six
minutes um and once again um when you're
comfortable ready to go i'll give you a
30 second warning towards the end but
otherwise feel free to start when you're
ready thank you okay
um i'm just here so it was
this is um
this application has been put in because
we previously put an application in for
two dwellings
uh it didn't meet uh the stratfor
council um spd there was no parking
provisions
uh we went back we took on board
everything that was said
uh our architects worked closely with
joseph um we've reduced the height
he requested us to do that
and we've put the parking spaces in
and there hasn't been any objections
from the town council highways
environmental health or the fire service
there are many on there
on craven lane that do support this
application
um they're they're on the portal um
currently the um
the site uh has planning for as a
function hall
uh which would generate a lot more
traffic if it was in use
um a lot more noise as well
uh with it being a quiet street
uh i've heard the objection um but where
we're locating the building is well
within the distance guidelines for
planning
um it is away from the other building
and to the right of where we are putting
our property uh there is already a
two-story building
um
so i i can't see we we're not we're not
up against it there is a road between us
um and the distance measurements are are
fine uh hence why the planning officer
has um
uh
has obviously put it forward for
approval
charles
well within your time thank you very
much members do we have any questions
for applicants
no
okay in that case mr walt thank you very
much for your contribution if you give
the what desk a quick wipe down that
would be great and while you're doing
that i will call forward councillor
crumb
okay
councillor cramp welcome good evening
hello i think you know the drill five
minutes i'll give you 30 second warning
whenever you're ready to start feel free
to
right thank you mr chairman and we want
that five minutes
this application is it's um a similar
application for the welfare centre came
not too long ago to build two houses uh
with no parking
and that was also recommended by officer
for granting
at the committee i spoke against it but
particularly against the spd on parking
and it was turned down and then it went
to the planet inspector and
he or she i can't remember it was my own
feeling now so i'll go he or she or they
um uh agreed with our decision
i think it's mainly due to the no
parking although this application is is
better
in my opinion it's still not right
and as the light council chris williams
used to say
if it's not right it's wrong
by
at the end of march 20
and latest figures i've got south almost
had 1100 houses
so it can be choosy to get things right
we don't have to particularly
uh have a knee-jerk decision
and
put things in place because the the
place is a nice orb because it's falling
down
so i don't think it's particularly in
keeping
with the street scene and i'll just go
through points in the report first the
letters of support
on the mata great design really i think
that's slightly poetic license in my
opinion
uh provides adequate parking which i
agree it does but should we be striving
just to have adequate parking should we
have better than adequate parking
in keeping with the street scene no i
don't agree existing building is an iso
yeah i couldn't agree more
but let's be choosy it doesn't mean to
say we have to put something in there to
replace it the first thing you know we
need to get this right
and again much less traffic than an
existing hut and asked us you mentioned
by the by the applicant and also in the
report
that um
the the welfare center had got to car
park and had functions well i can't
remember the last time there were
functions there
and it was a welfare center and it was
designed
because my mother took my brothers there
to be weighed and measured
and surprise surprise my mother couldn't
drive it was a good job from a road
safety point of view that my mother
couldn't drive by the way
um so personally um
i think that argument is a little bit
tenuous but i'll go on that point yeah
my concerns are over the height design
loss of light
joe could you put my wonderful david
body pictures up please um
so uh that's uh mr wright's
white's house over the road um as you
can see from its size it's something
small and with the the windows
it is mr
swift's bedroom um
that's the
[Music]
view from his kitchen with existing
hoodies you can see how close it is even
with my limited photography skills
um and just the other one joe please
and that is from from the bedroom um
see uh the proof uh the previous
objector um
has health issues and does spend quite a
bit of time in there and we are
concerned about the overlooking so um
i think my photography skills were
slightly better in here so that's why i
got the the job of uh coming forward
with the pictures
so i don't think it's quite right
um it is better
much better than the two uh pre um the
two houses with no planning uh no
parking obviously we didn't have any
planning because it got refused um but
yeah so that is my concern it's not
quite right it's it's almost there in my
opinion um and that is why the reason
i'm objecting to this
thank you very much councillor crump
members do you have any questions for
our war member please
no we're all very quiet tonight aren't
we
okay in that case mr crump mr crump
councillor crump thank you very much for
your contribution i can be hard out for
photography for weddings as well yeah
but if you couldn't
okay um so members we now move to points
of clarification do you have any points
clarification for our officers cancer
dixon first please
uh thank you answer yeah fundamentally
there is so the plan before you you can
see that would be obstacle glaze just in
the bathroom area this is providing a
light into the bedroom
it'll be a struggle to make that
obstacle glazing because you can see
that it's the only main dorm window
finding light into that area
okay thank you council mills please
thank you chairman uh joe um i want to
be
concerned about uh the height and and
to be able to see from
the proposed development into mr mr
wright's um
bedroom um
what is the height of this uh
this particular building the highway
and will they be able can someone
will they be able to see into the
opposite residence there's a few factors
to that the height is 8.7 meters
now
i can't
looking across the road and the
distances it could be possible if
somebody did go into that space area
there that they could look into one of
the window elevations of the door
the roof lights
the issue being and i've put this in my
report is that roof lights and windows
are acceptable underneath development
they do not have the same degree of
protection as normal windows so
fundamentally and i'll go to the first
try and help
any one of these drones along here as
long as it didn't go above four inches
outside that roof light could put them
in with no regard to overlooking
so it just doesn't have the same degree
of protection
so at the same time our spd even kind of
highlights that and that it will only
give
policy protection in respect to
elevational windows and gable windows
sorry joe so
someone actually could if they would it
is possible yes i don't deny it what it
is is half and this is why some planning
balance which is in my report
is one
they would have to be stood within that
area
the dwelling is set 8.7 metres so it's
certainly 21.5 million dollars across
the road so it would have to be stood in
that area and then two
through flights are fundamentally four
lights into the dwelling not instinct
because one government sees it as a very
small windowed area in which most people
won't be able to view into and they
don't have the same level of protection
and that's why we've come the
recommendation that
it would be a struggle if it went to
appeal in my opinion our committee
obviously can take a different view
thanks joe thank you thank you very much
counselor adam please
thank you um
joe i was wondering um
about the the roof lights in
the neighboring property
do you know um if there are any other
windows or dormers into that space at
all
and also additional questions on that do
you know what
the type of difference in um
so's floor level there is with the
windows um the reason i ask is because i
think there's a bit of a difference
between a roof light that's in the roof
directly above you and one that's a
roughly
window level as i think councillor
trump's photos might have suggested
the first answer is yes and i think i've
got some backup photos that can
demonstrate that
that's the free roof lights on the main
street i'm just trying to find it
they're the three leaf lights to the
rear so it does have additional roof
lights to the rear of the property so
that answers that question
in respect to the actual e says the
second floor onto the bedroom property i
don't have the specific information to
that based on the dwelling size itself
needs i would probably say it's there
and it wouldn't be a must i'll be honest
it wouldn't be a massive
second floor so there was very good
chance that you would be
sort of standing at head height looking
at that window
just quick follow-up then um because i
appreciate there are roof lights on the
back as well but because those are the
only
these collection of windows are the only
ways of getting natural light into this
room
um
but presumably this was a room when the
house was built as it were and these
weren't put in as permit development so
this was
the permission for this house across
road um that allows these to be
considered as windows as opposed to roof
lights is what i'm trying to get out i i
think i understand the question the
honest truth is i couldn't say when they
were put in because you're like doing
permanent development so it might well
be the case straight away or the minute
they were occupied i just wouldn't be
able to stay they don't need planning
for it
the
the other issue with that is you were
saying about loss of daylight i
my officers report i don't think loss of
data would be a major issue given the
separation distances the overlooking as
i've already convected that if somebody
stood within that window looked over i
do think that'd be an issue the loss of
daylight given the separation distances
and the position in the sun it's
obviously nothing nor east or west bases
coming around i don't think that would
be a major issue
um through the rooftop especially given
there is another three additional ones
to the rear
okay do we have any more points of
clarification at this stage
no
in that case let's move into debate who
would like to kick us off
councillor mills was just just beat you
there casamayo you mr chairman yeah i'm
i'm a little concerned that that someone
could actually see into the um
opposite
building um
i'm also concerned that that is very
high and
not fitting the street scene
as i can see it
but more so of the um
the privacy
this this might invade uh so um
i'll think it for a moment mr chairman
um let's see what others have to say
thank you
okay thank you very much councillor
dixon please
is that a formal proposal
thank you very much uh who would who
else would like to contribute towards
the debate i will need a seconder at
some stage
nobody
counselor adam thank you
um
i think i'm slightly airing on
um agreeing more with councillor mills's
comments
the issue i have is that i think that
although they are in an inclined roof
the windows in the neighboring property
are the only source of light that that
room has and so i would feel that those
are more windows and
skylights
in which case i think overbearing would
be a reasonable
issue
um which i think would start to change
the narrative in the officer's report
and
saying that if in the certain
circumstances somebody was to stand in
their dormer well they'll be entitled to
do that because it's their dormer to
look over i generally speaking the
scheme looks fine apart from this top
story which has the master bedroom in it
i notice it's a
appear appears to be a four bedroom
house whereas the neighboring properties
don't have the
um
half story as it were to the top which
is where i think the the street scene
thing comes into it a bit more if
he only had the
if he didn't have essentially that top
story i think i'd be absolutely fine
with it but i do think that based on the
how the windows are used across the
street
i'd say this does start to look uh
breaching the um
overlooking concerns
um
in spite of the way that the the
report's written i'm not comfortable
supporting it on that basis i don't know
how if that would be considered strong
enough to go against it so i'd hope for
some advice from our officers on that
really
okay thank you we'll come back to that
in just a moment um anyone else wants to
make a
cancer fleming please
yeah i'm sort of siding a bit with chris
and and lewis on this um
i i think if if the house had velek
style windows in it instead of vertical
dormers then i'd feel a bit more
comfortable with it because they
wouldn't have a direct look
um so i think from that perspective as
it stands
i would have to say that i would go
against the officers recommendation
is that proposal
not yet okay
i'll throw mighty pennies worth in at
the moment because it seems everyone's a
bit quiet tonight
um
to my mind
our officer has fully explored all
avenues and he has detailed tonight
during our questions to him uh planning
policy and the law in which we obviously
need to make our decision um and the
result of that is that he has come to a
conclusion that we should be granting
permission um and i would agree with
that so i am going to second councillor
dixon's proposal
uh which is to grant the application in
line with the office recommendation um
unless anyone else has anything they
would like to say at this point we will
be moving to a vote
does anyone else want to say anything at
this stage
council form
thank you um i am quite in agreement
with what uh councillors edmunds just
said it's a shame that it's not valid
windows instead of dormer windows that
would make things much easier to accept
so i just wanted to support that
okay thank you very much um in that case
i think we will move
cancer adam at the last minute
sorry chairman um i think
just on the basis of what i've heard in
the debate
i don't think i could go with a good
conscience with just going to the vote
as it is appreciating it appreciating
that it will come up first so i'd like
to have a counter proposal to
go against the officer's recommendation
on the basis of residential amenity
okay would anyone like to second
that castle mills are you seconding
thank you very much councilman the
second did that yes i do um now what we
will need to do is get your reasoning
for that shortly we do obviously have a
proposal that has been seconded to
granting loan with office recommendation
and that must be taken first so on the
basis of the discussion that we've just
had i'm pretty sure i know which way
this is going to go we will take a vote
on it so for those in favor of granting
in line with offers recommendation
please put your hands up now
three chair and those against
so that therefore fails so we will need
to move to our second uh proposal which
is to refuse
the recommendation or sorry refuse the
application i will need to have reasons
for that please cancel adam
um can i get some advice from the
officers just on the specific uh core
strategy clause relating to um
overlooking concerns in residential
meaning i'm just trying to find it on
the um document i've
got uh who would like to come in tracy
or joe who's nice
he's fundamentally cs9 in this respect
sunday cs9 especially given it is so fun
um in that case i'd say that it's um
in considering the neighbors the
neighbors windows as windows instead of
roof lights
i'd consider it to be in breach of cs9
design and distinctiveness uh on the
basis of overlooking concerns
sad enough
okay i will ask our officers to make a
comment on that
my only concern with that is saying that
we're considering the brew flights to be
no sorry the roof likes to be normal
windows and technically they are roof
lights i think we're better off just
saying that we have concerns it will
cause overlooking harm
on the neighboring resident and
maintenances
i'm generally happy with that for the
purposes of the wording is it possible
to have a a note attached to that
outside of the core wording of the
proposal
i think you're going to be struggling to
convince people that a skylight is not a
skylight as a window it is a skylight um
so i think on the basis of what joe has
just said i think that's your best bet
okay
tracy thank you chairman it's fair to
say that uh if the applicant was to
appeal the decision again the
inspector's only going to look at the
actual reason for refusal itself and not
any supplementary notes you might want
to add to a decision notice so that
reason of refusal does need to be
specific and precise uh bearing in mind
obviously that the uh uh
the planning inspectors has already
considered um
a similar development albeit of a larger
scale uh on this site already
thank you very much council fleming
your microphone on cancer family is your
microphone on please
yeah i mean cs9
sort of you can include privacy in that
and that's really where i would be
looking that uh loss of privacy and and
uh and overlooking overbearing that's
that's what i always get would that work
for for the officers
that is certainly the way i would go i
would go down the line of something
overlooking lots of privacy and
overbearing impact on the neighboring
immune system wording to be delegated to
you i think but you've got the general
consensus or sorry the general uh
thought process
that's adam are you happy we proceed on
that and certainly be happy with that
thank you chairman thank you casa mills
you happy as a second now absolutely mr
chairman okay marvelous in that case we
will move to a vote on that so um the uh
proposal that has been seconded is to
refuse planning application for uh
applying commission sorry for
application twenty one zero one two
seven four fuel uh for the reasons given
could i have a show of hands version in
favor of refusal
fortran and those against
three chairs uh in that case committee
resolves to refuse application twenty
one zero one two seven four full for the
reasons given
thank you very much members let's move
on to our next item
which is
item number application number twenty
one zero one eight three nine ful
southern college
in southam
our presenting officer is alison willis
allison once you have made yourself
comfortable do feel free to begin
should we say we're just going to take
one minute while we uh while we plug in
a new laptop forgive us of this um thank
you everyone for your patience uh so
we're just going to uh
have a one minute break
share yours now
okay we are all back now and i'm ready
to go so alison whenever you are ready
please do feel free to start
um thank you mr chairman
so this is an application
for the demolition of the existing
existing
well part of the existing southern
college
temporary teaching
accommodation and replacement with two
and a two and three-story new school
building
with associated outdoor recreation and
teaching space
enhanced bus drop-off facilities for
eight buses and parking areas and
associated infrastructure
it's on the
ex all on the existing
southern college site to the north west
of southam
so the development will provide
accommodation for an identical number of
students
as are currently accommodated on the
site
this is the application site the red
line is around the perimeter of the
college
the site is outside the conservation
area and is not close to any listed
buildings
this is the existing leisure centre here
and the nearby primary school
here is a recent aerial view of the site
showing the application site outlined in
red
you'll see that there is open
countryside to the north and the west
so
here are some
recent pictures of the existing college
so this is the existing access onto
welsh road
which is the main entrance
this is the main reception
maths and teaching block
which is being retained
the rear of the main school building
the relatively new teaching
music block
and the new sports hall
so this slide shows
before and after imagery of the site
so this picture here is the existing
site
so the main mass of the building is here
it's four stories
and
in this slide shows the proposed
development so the main new building is
here
it's
mainly
three and two and three stories and it's
pushed further back into the site
the three-star story element of this
building of the new building is located
furthest away from the nearest houses
along this boundary
and the building height obviously
decreases
in height the closer you get to the
eastern boundary
the buildings
in the in the existing site the
buildings to the west of the red dotted
line
are to be retained so these buildings
here
and
the mass of the main buildings here are
to be removed in in
phases as mentioned the replacement
building is to be pushed further back
into the site
and then one of the main advantage of
this is to allow the introduction of a
courtyard here
and improved parking and drop-off
facilities for cars and buses
so in slightly more detail
the replacement building
is pushed back the three-story
t-shape here
with two stories here
it's the same
uh in and out access as is current
currently
but there is
improved parking and bus facilities
drop-off facilities
within the site
so there's a landscaped entrance
courtyard
the playing fields and pitches remain
the same
and the trees on the perimeter around
here and down the eastern boundaries are
being retained
so
these are some images of the of the new
proposed school
the external materials are intended to
be both contemporary and neutral
the majority of the building's facades
comprise
comprise two tones of grey brick
so fairly muted
the external materials are supplemented
in places by splashes of color to assist
with wayfinding around the site
the building has been designed to
achieve a net net zero carbon in
operation
using passive solar techniques and
energy reduction a number of active
measures are also proposed including
heat pumps for heating and hot water and
heat recovery on the ventilation systems
in terms of the practical details
the development is proposed over five
phases
these
red buildings will be demolished in
phase two
and the replacement
building which is the main
bulk of the
new building
will be
built in its footprint
so
the original building
here
will
remain
uh
well through
a fair chunk of the development
there is a need for an additional
teaching block temporary teaching block
which will be located here
outside
to the rear of the sports hall
but still within the site
um
so
this slide shows the enhanced parking
arrangements
for dropping off and turning areas
so as i mentioned it's the same existing
in and out here
and here
but there is revised space here for
eight buses so these are bus parking
spaces
plus additional space for additional
buses to stop alongside them and pass
them whilst they're parked
so
the car there's car parking spaces
provided within the site
same number as there is currently
there's
four electrical vehicle charging points
four additional disability spaces
uh 16 cycle spaces with the capacity for
a total of 120 spaces subject to demand
so
in terms of the comparison
of the building heights
section bb is shown in the top picture
so you can see the existing school
building which is the red dotted line
and the new building which is this grey
building
so
there is a around a two meter difference
between the existing and the proposed
the proposed being two meters
smaller
these are some views
um
[Music]
of the existing
building the existing four-story
building
so there are from the north and the west
fairly fleeting views of the site
[Music]
so you can see
here
from the public right-of-way to the
north west
and if you can see in here this is the
bp garage
as you drive
on the way out of southam to the north
and you can just see the top of the
building
over the hedgerow and i don't know if
you can see it on there
um
and here again from the
from the coventry road you can see the
the top of the building here
and from
just a gap in the just a gap in a short
gap in the hedgerow so you can see the
top of the building there as
well so
so obviously the new building will be
materially lower
and it will be made from a subdued
pallet of materials
as i said predominantly grey brick
so
this is um
a panoramic panoramic view taken looking
north from the back of the school from
the existing school
and it demonstrates that the mature
the the amount of mature boundary
hedgerow
and trees um along the perimeter around
the perimeter of to the north and the
west
um and obviously these these mature
trees will help to filter out any
glimpsed views
of the site anyway
thank you mr chairman that's the end of
my presentation
there's one update as per the update
sheet
the recommendation is that the
application be granted for the reasons
detailed in the report subject
conditions and notes the wording and
numbering of which is delegated to
officers
thank you awesome thank you very much
indeed let's move to our first speaker
on this item who is counsellor angela
john again counselor welcome back do you
make your way forward
grab a seat
in the same way as before you have three
minutes and i'll give you a 30 second
warning before your your time is up and
if you could remain seated for questions
afterwards that'd be great otherwise
whenever you're ready thank you
thank you for the opportunity to comment
further on the southern town council's
objection and in particular the points
raised in the planning offices report
the comments made by the planning
officer on landscaping and divine are
noted but we respectfully disagree with
the analysis of both the applicants and
the planning officer
an opportunity for a truly outstanding
piece of design and or architecture that
either blends in better with the
surroundings or makes an iconic
statement for the town and wider
district has been lost
however
more worrying though is the lack of any
real response to the current unsafe
nature of the welsh road west at the
start and the end of the school day
this has been witnessed firsthand by an
officer from warwickshire county council
safety engineering team on a recent site
visit with southern town council
currently the college has around 1 600
pupils of which 1100 are transported by
coach
this requires a minimum of 16 high
capacity single decker coaches twice a
day
the college currently has capacity for
seven coaches meaning that at school
pick-up time
nine additional coaches have to queue on
the welsh road west competing with car
pedestrian and cycle traffic there is
the addition of the traffic to southern
primary school and southern leisure
centre both within 500 yards of the
college
this proposal only guarantees one
additional coach space making eight this
is entirely insufficient to deal with
the existing traffic management problems
the applicant's traffic assessment
suggests that the prose car parking lot
in front of the college could
accommodate up to 16 coaches however
this
accommodation prevents the use of the
events the 40 car parking spaces
including disabled spaces it also
requires that all 16 coaches need to be
double parked
there is no condition requiring this
plan to be put in place and reality
there are two problems with this option
all the coaches would need to be
occupied before prior to or any of them
departing this is unlikely to happen
once it's known that the 40 car parking
spaces in the coach area get blocked for
a period each day the incentive to use
them by staff pupils and visitors will
be dramatically reduced
the plans also show coach parking based
upon school buses at a little over 11
metres in length
the current high capacity single decker
coaches are up to 15 meters in length
this would require an additional space
of between 32 meters only 64 meters for
coach parking
none of the above has been considered in
the traffic assessment nor the county
highways response and raises significant
questions on the scheme's ability to
actually provide any of the promised
additional coach provision
within the lifetime of the proposed
building both the number of pupils
attending the college and the way in
which they get to and from the college
will change however there is no planning
condition requiring a review of the
traffic management at the college should
people answer john i'm afraid that is
your time up so i'm going to have to ask
you to wrap up with your sentence i had
actually finished really
last sentence so that however there is
no planning condition requiring the
review of traffic management at the
college should people numbers or travel
makeup alter thank you lovely thank you
very much indeed members do we have any
questions for our counsellor
no counselor mills please
thank you hello good evening um
i i've been to see the site and the the
school as it is is quite high isn't it
yeah that's know tip four stories yes
um
and it's been reduced in height
yes so it is
apart you don't look anything of it do
you
um
is it the height that's worried you or
is it is it the we have some concerns
about the the landscape and design to be
honest our main concerns are about
highway safety
um
we did feel that um the building could
have looked more attractive more iconic
etcetera and perhaps use slightly
different materials but if i'm honest
our main objection is around and or
concern is around traffic management
okay thanks thank you
thank you cancer mills remembers any
other questions
no in that case council john thank you
very much for your contribution
okay um our next speakers on this item
will be uh mr racket charmer
and kirsty clifton i believe is here as
well because if you want to come up to
the seats on the right hand side and
kirsty is here for questions only i
believe
mr samara hello good evening um you have
three minutes and i'll give you 30
second warning we did go over by 10
seconds previously so i will allow an
extra 10 seconds for you so i'll give
you a 30 second warning before your
three minutes and 10 is up otherwise
when you're already open to you okay my
name is ranjit samra i'm the head
teacher of southern college i've been
headteacher for the last 12 years
um school was built in 1958 for 600
pupils over that time and it served the
community very very well the staff
students it's an outstanding school it's
been outstanding twice in its last
offsteads and has grown
1650 students
um but it was built in 1958 and it is
like an old car started to break down
we are currently having to spend
hundreds of thousands of pounds each
year in its maintenance for example in
the integrated buildings which is one of
the reasons that school was chosen out
of one out of 55 schools nationally so
when we received news that we were one
of those schools that was going to be
possibly rebuilt we were over the moon
with that
as i said it's costing hundreds of
thousands of pounds in not only the
building but also the heating it's very
inefficient
and it's costing more and more and
that's only going to go further and
further up
so we've got a real concern with it
as i said when we were one of the first
schools to be notified that we were one
of the 55 schools to be built we were
over the moon with this
and we've worked very diligently with
the architects with the department for
education who are funding the build
and in consultation with senior leaders
highly talented architects and a the
national rebound contractor we feel
we've got a school which is fit for
purpose and what we wanted was a school
which we felt was fit for purpose future
proof and had a wow factor we feel this
school in its design delivers that um we
are very concerned about that because
it's about raising aspirations we want
students to feel that they have an
iconic building and that they are not
part of a market town and they can be
global citizens we think this school
will deliver that
it will also though really push the
boundaries on sustainability and we've
been extremely impressed with the work
and time and effort which has gone into
the landscaping and also the
consultation that we're having with our
own sixth formers about how it will be
um
very self-sufficient in its energy
output
as i said the school reflects the needs
of the staff and the parents and the
staff we've put together a three design
3d design in our reception and that has
had an overwhelmingly positive response
from students parents any other visitors
at school it is something that we are
all desperate for
in terms of the objections from the
council um and we've had a very uh
a very
mature discussion with the council and i
know the council would like a school to
be built in a brand new area in a brand
new site
which would be away from southern and i
get that and that's nirvana
but it isn't going to happen and the dfe
aren't going to fund it this is a
pragmatic solution to a very very
serious problem 30 seconds which will
allow us to sustain the great school
that we've got
in terms of the traffic congestion welsh
road west is a very narrow road there is
no two ways about that but we feel with
the design of this school we will be
able to bring more of the coaches on
site the coaches don't all come at the
same time
they are staggered so we don't you know
we don't have 16 coaches all on site at
the same time and i have to ask you to
wrap up now okay so finally i would say
that we accept um
that this will will improve the parking
the congestion it isn't the ideal
solution but it will be much better than
what we have and that is the main
objection of the
marcus thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions council
adam first please
thanks um i'm just wondering uh in terms
of capacity um obviously the this
considers that there isn't going to be
an increase in student numbers in the
immediate term do you know if there are
any thoughts or plans about increasing
numbers particularly with
we've worked very closely with county
council and certainly we know that in
the short and medium term there is no
requirement for the school to expand i
can't obviously comment on 10 years time
but certainly within that fame from a
time frame that's the feedback and we
also know that watch county council are
very supportive
okay that's really useful thank you very
much
council mills first please thank you
good good evening um
there was a main concern from the
council about the um
the traffic uh
are you saying that the coaches are
staggered when they i mean is that a
planned stagger coming out or
a planned stagger would be perhaps being
two kinds
they do not all turn up at the same time
being the vagueries of the coach drivers
and where they they come from very
different
areas
i think something else we need to factor
into this is that our sports hall we've
been
we have access for additional coach
parking spaces there we haven't been
able to utilize that because we had some
works which are ongoing those should be
completed by september
thank you yeah so
when the other schools in kingston is
being rebuilt as well and we had the
same problem with traffic so thank you
thank you very much cancer council crumb
please council mills one of my questions
is could you look at another one um
obviously i know about the uh very well
it's my county award uh and i know about
the zebra crossing
um in that in that area um
obviously
i'm keen to encourage safe and
sustainable truck travel to school and i
know what actually came to council i've
got some sato safe and
safer travel offices
are you working with warwickshire county
council to encourage more sustainable
walking cycling yeah absolutely we are
trying as you know
as much as possible to get students to
walk and to cycle and some of the
surrounding areas doesn't make that as
as easy as it possible as it could be
and there's also sometimes a culture of
traveling like that
and that's something that we are working
very very explicitly um with all
partners to try encourage students to do
that
very good members do we have any other
questions at this point please
council plumbing
i i see from the presentation that
you're aiming for a carbon neutral
school
obviously we have a
climate change emergency here
as part of the climate change panel um
surely
do you see that you can be carbon
neutral you that you're going to reduce
your your power consumptions and
whatever else is it going to be a green
a green building if you like that's
absolutely i think one of the dfp
requirements
um
sorry i'm going to tell you can you tell
me my phone because i can't know what
you're saying thanks
um yeah i mean the dfe highlighted for
this scheme particularly that they
wanted a um a carbon neutral school in
operation and that's something that
they've funded because obviously the
actual cost of that
is is significant in the in the build um
and therefore it's been assessed by the
um by the contractor in terms of
actually what the outputs will be um
associated with all of the scheme
okay thank you very much
marvelous if there are no further
questions which it doesn't look like
there are let's thank you very much both
of you for your contribution this
evening we will move on if you could
turn your microphone off as well please
mr thank you very much
okay we have no further registered
speakers on this item so we will move to
points of clarification to our officers
would anyone like to ask a question to
our officers councilor mills
thank you um
allison the the height of the
proposed new proposal it's you'd say
it's
is it 20
you say 20 or 22 meters
long 2 meters 20. there's no 2 meters
lower
it's 2 meters long so it's 13.65 meters
to the top of the parapet right and um
is it
cited further away from um residential
buildings or
the proposed
so
if you can see that's that's obviously
the tallest bit
and in this building
it's this bit that's the tallest bit
there's t here
so that it'll be less of a hit when you
walk and when you and i've looked at it
and you've got this also step further
back from
it is set but that's one thing
thanks thank you very much okay do we
have any other points for application
for officers
council grant
yeah just a couple of things i think
obviously i know the area well and i
would say it's probably a lot further
away from some but closer to one to two
potentially but i'm not going to the
point i know what it is and i think that
the main main points on that is is it's
further away um
my point and my concern again is is to
do with highways and i noticed there is
a condition uh regarding um
parking maneuvering the cars and buses
and delivery vehicles and construction
management
um
has there been any further updates on
that or was oh like was that the final
like that happy with that
um because there's no increase in pupil
numbers the highways authority was
relatively
um
confident that the current proposals are
a betterment if you like
um and i've had conversations with the
highway authority and if you know in the
longer term if the school needed did
need to expand with increased pupil
numbers and that would obviously be
subject to a new planning application
with a transport assessment and road
safety audit
so
so they've had no
um there's no no further comments from
highways authorities
both to there
and
it's almost follow what it's
the actual build itself it's been
designed
that it can take
further expansion um
you just can't find that one yes we've
been we've talked about that um we had a
pre-app before we had the planning
application and that was one of the
first things that we all discussed um i
think there's been quite a lot of
discussions um between the academy trust
and the county council and the
dv
um and we've talked about where future
expansion could go within the site
at the moment
uh i think they're trying not to
encroach upon the playing fields
um
but there's plenty of scope
within the
the periphery of where the existing the
proposed buildings are to expand so
we've had quite a few discussions about
that
answer adam did i see you had a hand up
earlier um councillor crump sort of beat
me to it marvellous unless anyone else
have any points of clarification we'll
move to the debate who would like to
kick us off the debate councillor dixon
please
cancer ejection is your microphone on
i'm i'm struggling to hear you as well
i think your microphone might be
knackered
could you potentially turn cancer
fleming's across you and then while you
speak we'll just have we're just going
to have to make do with what we've got
thank you sorry let's uh oh that's
better isn't it yes i can sympathize
with the idea that uh an iconic building
might have been nice etc but bearing in
mind you're only dealing with the
redevelopment of half of the site
uh it isn't really a facility which is
available and obviously we always have
to look at what's actually presented to
ourselves as to what we might in an
ideal world have seen
when it comes to the highways issues
obviously it can is a concern of the
parish council town council
but essentially given that highways have
no objection to this one
essentially i'm going to be supporting
the officer's recommendation and i would
propose that we grant it german
marvelous thank you very much um i am
going to put in mighty penis worth in
now i can hardly agree with you i can
only see no planning reason why we would
overturn this so i will be seconding
your proposal counselor adam please
marvelous thank you very much um
unless anyone has anything that
desperately pressing they want to say i
think we can probably move to the vote
yeah let's move to the vote we have a
proposal to grant uh in line with
officer officer's recommendation it has
been seconded please show of hands for
those in favor
unanimous job in that case committee
therefore resolves to grant application
2101839ful
marvelous thank you very much everyone
let's move on to our next item
now um to add a slight complication to
the mixed members of the committee we
have uh had a request from both parish
council and ward member to defer this
item and i'm going to refer to our
solicitor in just a moment who will
detail why we've had that deferral
request it is then for the committee to
vote on whether we defer or whether we
hear this item tonight we choose to hear
it tonight we will carry on as normal
otherwise we will just move on to our
next slide
so
whenever you are ready if you give us
the reasons why we're being asked to
defer
thank you chair
the
reason um that the parish council and
the world member have put forward is
that when um the original proposal was
sent to
knapton parish council in 2019
um
it appears that it may have been dealt
with by email correspondence instead of
um
a proper a proper meeting uh where
minutes uh would have minuted any
conversation
um i haven't seen any minutes actually
confirm
the uh footpath matter was discussed
um so basically we've moved on since
then um both the war member and the
parish council have given approval
to the um second
um
proposal which i'm going to show you one
may show you later
uh
but a lot of water has gone under the
bridge since then and we're nearly
nearly two years down the line
and um
the parish council have made a request
that because a certain parish councillor
will benefit
from this application
they want to take this back to their
committee
so
basically it is properly minuted
and
the public get the chance to
um basically have another sale on this
but i would say
that um as for the actual application
the process of the footpath i have done
everything that it that should be done
and
this matter is before you because we
have an objection so the process worked
because the objects were objected
so it went on site it went in the local
post
and it also went on the parish notice
board
but because of property and transparency
uh the parish council requesting that
um it is taken it is delayed for a month
i mean it's been going on for two two
odd years so
um
it's delayed for a month so they can
actually
discuss it at a parish council meeting
like i said just for transparency and
property
issues
nice thank you very much members you
will see in your update sheet full
details of those comments and you will
also have received a written
version or a typed up version of the
objection that we have received um so
the vote or the what i'm asking you now
to do is to
confirm or otherwise uh your agreement
to defer so if i could please have a
show of hands for those in favor of
deferment
one two three four one six six those
against
just two so in that case committed
therefore results to defer this item
until next uh well for a month until our
next going to meet him
okay thank you very much indeed let's
move on to our
next item
okay we do need to get joe brook back
into the room so we will just take one
second while joe comes back down and
plugs in his laptop
a lot of this moving around and freddy
is because of covered rules keeping
certain people in certain places and
distances and things so please do bear
with
us chair
actually
okay
okay
yes
okay so our next item this evening is
application number twenty one zero zero
seven three zero fuel did windmill farm
bamboo road our presenting officers joe
brook joe over to you
thank you chair
just get out
the application site is located on his
feedback from the computer project
how does that
the application is located on the open
countryside at windmill farm just
outside the red horse veil business
estate as indicated by the black dot
before you
the application is seeking planning
permission to develop a new two-story
four-bedroom dwelling to be occupied by
a rural worker to support the existing
rural business red horse rail at
windmill farm
the proposed one is located to the west
of the existing industrial space this is
opposed to welding
and the estate itself is an appearance
of buildings merchants i'll show photos
in president
and with the garden center and retail
element which also include external
sales areas the large mental cloud
storage buildings are also situated to
the west of the center of the state
so you're looking across their storage
buildings
a padded is located to the north beyond
the industrial state and open
countryside is situated to the west
so come to countries on the west island
well it's a two-story white rendered
wedding with a rear conservatory and
front extensions construct that red
brick is situated to the south east
that is the dwelling in itself
public footpath passes directly through
the western side of the site
so the prowl extends across here
and extends outwards
the dwelling will be located to the west
of the industrial state circa 21 meters
and construct our red brick plain clay
roof tiles with an owl shaped layout as
the plans indicate for you as well in
the street you've seen
so these are the photos this is
obviously google earth just because it
gives the best perspective of red
horsepower on the building site access
would be obtained through there but
obviously this is the access to the
industry itself
this is leading in through the
industrial area access obviously you can
see the many uses in the metal card
buildings and so forth
various uses on the scheme metallized
metal club buildings clutches sales
areas outdoor sales areas etc
this is the existing dwelling on site
just outside the industrial state
rear the existing dwelling which faces
out onto its own cartilage there you go
that's the cartilage and coming down my
ways where the
training would be set so i see access
point coming in
and that's the end of the presentation
in consideration the area's development
plan including development
considerations part cs10 as well as
national policy and guidance the officer
recommendation is for refusal
you will also see on the update sheet
additional information has to be
provided in the form of a justification
statement this has been adequately
subluxed completely assessed by the
officer thank you chair
thank you very much um our speak first
speaker on this item is councillor
stuart of ox hill parish council council
stuart if you'd like to make your way
forward
good evening and welcome thank you for
your patience this evening
um in line with all of the speakers
you'll have three minutes i'll give you
a 30 second warning whenever you're
already do feel free to start okay thank
you um the parish council doctor would
like to support this application
unfortunately our um support for this
was recorded under parish clark's name
which said there's no record of it as a
parish council comment
um we think the designs of proposed
dwelling shows an attractive distinctive
character in keeping with the local area
although the plan shows an inclusion of
black box if successful we would like to
see how the proposal will meet the
requirements to improve energy
efficiency using renewable energy for
example solar air source rain rain water
harvesting
horse is not only a large employer in
the locality providing local people
employment but it has diversified
enabling local people from local
communities to access a range of
products without the need to travel far
both the size of the site and the value
of good stores there has increased
having a second property providing
on-site accommodation would not only
increase the site security but would
negate the need for the owner to travel
to and from work on a daily basis
given recent global events reducing
journeys is something that we should be
encouraging
for these reasons the parish council
supports this application
of us that is within your time thank you
very much members do we have any
questions for our councillor please
no in that case thank you very much for
your contribution
we will move then to our next speaker
who is our agent for the application
natasha de silva
she did
good evening and welcome again thank you
for your patience um you have three
minutes 30 second warning whenever
you're ready do feel free to start
uh good evening i am here to speak in
support of this application for the new
dwelling at windmill farmox hill i thank
the case officer and consultees for
their constructive feedback and
assistance to date
policy as10 allows for dwellings for
occupation by a person engaged in a form
of use that can only be only reasonably
carried out in the countryside
red horse fails limited as is an
established fuel and country supply
business which has been on this site
since 1977.
due to its scale and type it would be
unreasonable to expect the business to
move to a more central location
therefore its continued operation can
only be reasonably carried out in the
countryside
it currently has 30 employees and it is
vital that the business can continue to
operate sustainably
the business sells several expensive
items including building and trade
supplies fuel is also sold via pumps
without adequate security these are
particularly vulnerable to theft
the businesses isolated location puts it
at risk of theft and vandalism and
having a dwelling on site tied to the
business will ensure that there is a
constant natural surveillance to deter
crime lot gates and cctv are just not
sufficient on their own
the dwelling's presence will help to
dissuade criminals from targeting the
business
the functional need for the dwelling in
line policy as-10 is clear but there are
also financial considerations associated
with providing sufficient security
in his report the case officer suggests
that a security guard would be a viable
alternative
however the annual salary for security
guard at present is between 20 and 25
000 pounds a year adjusted for inflation
this would increase to around 24 and a
half to 30
by 2031.
in total the cost of a security guard
over this 10-year period would be in the
region of 222
to 277 in a half thousand
whereas the cost of the build for the
drilling would be 190 to 200 000
thereabouts
it is unviable for the applicants to
employ a security guard when the cost
will be significantly more than the cost
for constructing the dwelling
additionally the cost of a security
guard is open-ended and will need to be
paid annually for the business and the
duration of the business which will
likely stand far far longer than the
10-year period assessed above it's
already been on site for 44 years at
this point
in summary the proposed dwelling is the
most viable way of guaranteeing the
continued security and functionality of
the business and the applicants are
happy for a condition restricting
occupation to those
working for red horse fails limited
currently in the intention is for one of
the directors to occupy the building
we hope that this is a straightforward
decision to approve the scheme in line
with policy as 10 and trust that members
will agree
i am happy to answer any questions you
may have thank you mr silva thank you
very much council dixon please
good evening
you mentioned obviously that a security
guard has been costed has any costumes
been done regarding camera cctv and
other security issues which the officer
suggested might be considered as an
alternative to residential accommodation
there are already some cctv cameras on
the shop
um as far as i know the applicant hasn't
looked into adding any additional cctv
cameras their thinking was that if they
were living on site
that would the deterrent of the natural
surveillance would be sufficient
do we have any other questions uh
councillor crump please
yeah thank you um
could you tell me why a four-bedroom
house in particular um
um the applicant has that many kids and
needs a full bedroom house
specifically specifically for him that's
what he required to be able to move on
to the site
he needed a house of that size
okay thank you
okay thank you thank you council fleming
yeah see there is already a house on the
site
but they're saying that that's not
connected to the business it's not tied
in any way now so you can't
you can't rely on them to ring the
police if this if somebody's there but
it would be unfair to rely on somebody
to stay in that house all the time
anyway so from a security point of view
if you want need somebody on site you
would need the second house if that's is
that what what you're actually saying
that's our thinking even if there is
someone on site if the house isn't tied
to the business even if it was tied to
the business you can't expect them to be
in there 24 7. having an additional
house as a additional deterrent yeah
that's the point i'm trying to make yeah
that's all i was asking thank you very
much
okay unless you have any other questions
it doesn't look like we do mr thanks
very much for contributing if you could
give the desk a quick wipe down that'd
be great and while you're doing that
we'll call forward our note speaker
who's counselor fleming uh cancer
fleming sorry cancer feeling sorry
you're sat right next to me how's it
feeling come on down
cancer fielding i think you know the
drill five minutes 30 second warning use
as much or a little as little time as
you like and whenever you're ready do
feel free to start
don't forget to put your microphone on
i've asked
joe if he could do
yeah can you come
come out a bit from that
now what i wanted to show is anyway
i agree that this is in a rural location
there are mitigating circuits
that must be considered for granting
this application
there have been increase in rural crime
to the west is hogwarts pig farm that
has been subject to a great deal of
vandalism this has forced the farmer
into winding up the business due to the
adverse press
on the opposite side of the road is red
wings or sanctuary and again items have
been stolen from this site
in radway the riding stables had 50 000
pounds worth of riding equipment stolen
and within the last four weeks a
parishioner in oxford had his caravan
stolen in a very professional military
manner
it is notable how professional the
criminals are these days
rural
locations have seen an increase in crime
business such as red hot fields
needs to have good security other
aspects of
running a business of this natures are
the delivery of products
that must be somebody on call to allow
these to take place
red horse fuel supplies both diesel and
central heating oil to the local
community which are high value products
there are cases of farm and domestic
fuel tanks being drained in the area
there's a shortage of affordable homes
in this area that it is not possible to
provide accommodation in the close
proximity red redhorse fields
the accommodation is being built
for an assistant
stroke partner in this business
as with as-10 one it is practical for
all workers to live close to their
employment
it is unfair that the brothers who
are
who live on site sorry it is unfair that
the brother who lives on site has sole
responsibility for security
therefore the need for additional
accommodation is important
one of the brothers needs
excuse this
to be on site at all times when the
other wants to take a holiday or a break
the close-up proximity of the partners
in is important for the well-being
and their working relationship
council funding thank you very much
members do we have any questions for
cancer filling council dixon please
thank you chairman kessler fielding um
you mentioned uh theft from neighboring
properties the pig farm i think and the
other one etc uh can you tell me whether
or not there's any residential
accommodation on those sites where those
thefts occur
well that's um where the caravan was
stolen from yes
the owner was living was it was 1 30 in
the morning
he i was thinking of the other you
mentioned uh i think the caravan was the
third item that you mentioned where
they've been
are these directly relevant planning
considerations for this application
i fear they're not and we're going in
the wrong direction
it's basically a situation chairman
whereby
uh councilor fielding was trying to make
a a case for
uh security and the need for residential
accommodation i think as a
deterrent to theft and he was citing
examples of theft
where
if i if there was no residential
accommodation in those other situations
then essentially i was basically
i think cancer fielding has made his
case about the need in terms of security
i don't want to explore each individual
a case of theft to see whether there was
a house there or not his case has been
made i don't it's not a relevant
planning consideration
do we have any other questions for
cancer fielding please
no in that case cancer feeling thank you
for your contribution uh we will move
now to uh questions and points of
clarification to our offices does anyone
have a
question for our opposites please
councilman mills
thanks michelle um joe if we could go on
to the site itself
okay
is it possible to show
on the site where this house is going to
be
or not
um
what do you mean i'm through the
photographs yes
so he's quite a regular size so i
probably need to go back to some more
additional for hers
just doesn't seem to
so it's fundamentally
30 seconds i can get that back
i've been
a really good time on my team this one
so if you go back to the photos
here if this is pretty much taken from
the sort of
the position where the dwelling will be
cited
yeah so it comes down here left and then
what you do is you you'll be over to the
right there and then you obviously dwell
in and then it will be coming through
this area and set to the rear of it
the site is very condensed and the one
reason for the photos like i mean that
when i was on site there was a lot of
debris and
rubble and so forth on there for the
industrial workings on the site
gonna get my head the so the rear of the
property will it look out onto this
field
yeah so if you go back to the side plan
and it's easiest one to show
so yeah the rear the the l-shaped unit
itself so you can see that
that's what we'll be positioning now on
fundamentally to the dwelling in the
industrial state including that
elevation and then the rear will be
looking to the north and the west and
and the front will be looking onto the
the front so be that elevation and that
elevation there which we'll be looking
on to it oh and that sorry that would
that would be looking onto the site it's
i'll be looking onto the site yeah
what's on the layout yes yeah thank you
okay unless there's a question i've got
one i will put forward um joe i think
you've covered this in your report but
just so i've got my understanding
absolutely right
security workers are they considered
uh as rural workers
like required rural workers is that
correct or are they separate from a role
worker in terms of definition
do you mean like security guards already
own of the business can i just ask well
for security purposes ultimately this is
for security purposes isn't it it's it's
fundamentally but it's more the location
for it so the location for it makes it
an agricultural workers dwelling because
it's in the open countryside we don't
have an argument against that the
business itself
is in the open countryside and if it was
deemed that security is a central need
on the site for a dwelling then it would
meet the requirement of the worker and
that's what i wanted to be clear on and
now i am thank you very much okay
castleford
thank you um could i just ask um if if
it was to be granted can a condition be
put on that it had to be a little worker
that lived there and is that condition
subject to a date or is this
continuous
thank you
yeah that condition would be in vote on
it for a worker problem tied to the
business in this case and it would be
continuous unless they sought to remove
the condition at a later date
so if they sought to remove the
condition they'd have to come back to
planning to do that that's correct yeah
thank you
okay unless there are any other
questions we'll move into the debate who
would like to kick us off councillor
dixon
thank you chairman
there are a lot of rural businesses and
a lot of garden centers without any
residential accommodation
i can understand
the request there is accommodation
already on the site and what is actually
being proposed is a very large detached
residence which if all that was required
was accommodation for a security person
you would not actually need such a large
establishment as the proposed dwelling
so i will be supporting the officer's
recommendation for refuse and i will
propose that this application is refused
thank you very much cancer dickson who
would like to go next council mills
thanks ms chairman yes um
i drove on to the site and i looked
where i
think the um
the proposed welding is going to be
um
i mean i think we've talked about
worried about if it was sold on i can't
think anybody in their right mind would
want to buy that you know because it
just looks onto a site it's it's
dreadful um
if you
the um as i understand that the
the applicant need has got four children
as well um so he needs a large
he needs a large building um
i'm not too i
quite like the idea of more security on
this site it is in the middle of nowhere
that's for sure thank you
okay thank you very much cancer miles
counselor adam
thank you um
i can appreciate where the applicant's
coming from
um but i think
from looking at the report and what um
the officers said
the evidence hasn't been provided to
justify it as an essential
requirement for the site
if the applicant wanted to go away and
come back with a more evidence to that
effect then we might reconsider it but
at this point i can't see material
um
reasons to to go against the planning
officer's recommendations so i'm happy
to to second councillor dixon's proposal
lovely thank you very much council adam
councillor crump
yeah i'm saying in my first application
i said yeah it's it was better but not
quite right and i think this is the same
so i want to be consistent on on that
approach i think it has got some merits
but isn't quite right and as council
wins used to say it is wrong
so therefore um
to be consistent with my my objection in
the first one i will be going with the
officer's recommendation but i agree
with the comments made by councillor
thank you very much anyone else for any
more before i chuck my two pennies for
us in
no um
i think i'm inclined to agree with
cancer adam um i in principle i don't
particularly have an issue with this and
i can see there is a desperate need for
security uh but there are other
alternatives that don't appear to be
explored and if that evidence is
provided to us we may well be having a
very different discussion tonight so in
lieu of that uh evidence not being here
i think we our only option really is to
go with the officer's recommendation so
uh the proposal that has been put to us
is to refuse in line with the offer
recommendation let's move to a vote
could we have a show of hands for those
in favor of refusal
that is unanimous in that case
i do apologize for those against
thank you mr chairman i think you must
have been picking it up ready to go
after and i caught you so um committee
therefore resolves to refuse application
twenty one zero zero seven three zero f
u l that's one mill farm in ox hill
okay let's move on to
our next item
which is application number twenty one
zero zero two nine seven full land off
chapel street in warmington
our presenting officers once again joe
brooke
osu joe thank you chair the application
site is located in the physical confines
of warmington as indicated by the black
dot before you it should also be noted
that in accordance with pulses cs15 and
cs16 warnington is defined as an order
of assertment this definition is set out
in the officers report
the application is seeking planning
permission for the development of a
single dwelling the application site is
within the warmington conservation area
and in close proximity to the grade 2
listed cartons cottage circa 28 metres
to the northeast and grade 2 listed plow
the public house circa 30 minutes to the
southeast
as demonstrated on plan for you so just
in some indication this is the
conservation area in swept that's the
plow and that's craven's cottage that's
obviously the application site
the dwelling would be set seven meters
to ridge and is proposed to be
constructed out natural stone and slate
where a symmetrical layout for the
fenestration a small intimate courtyard
will be situated and solar panels are
proposed to rear elevation
this gives you an indication of the
street scene with the garage as well as
the west elevation and the differences
in levels
[Music]
this is obviously elevational plans
i sat on the report quite a standard of
traditional design really with solar
panels to the rear elevation
four-pound two-bedroom layout with the
two bathrooms overlooking
um with offshore glazing
proposed
so this is the entrance into the
application site it's just situated
there on the left the van is where the
parking is proposed
this is rose cottage and this is a great
two listed building
this is the application site itself
taken from the road leading downwards
you can see the street scenes
this is then looking back out onto the
main road where the bus stop and so
forth so this is rose cottages and the
grade two listed building this is the
parking element with the garage and
where the vans parked
this is the site itself is fundamentally
an open site and appreciate there is
some miscellaneous items but it is an
open site
and these are the surrounding properties
taken within the site so this is rose
cards itself this is looking along the
street seeing along that's the same
dwelling challenge but a better
perspective and that's rose cottage and
looking onto the grade two listed
building
and that's the end of presentation
in consideration the areas develop plan
include in the development
considerations
as well as national policy and guidance
as well as what's out in the development
requirements spd officer recommendation
is for refusal
uh there are no updates to thank you joe
thank you very much indeed our first
speaker on this item is councillor hyatt
from warmington parish council council
hyatt
thank you again for your patience to
make your way forward
while you're doing so once again i'll
reiterate the rules three minutes i'll
give you a 30 second warning if you
could stay seated with questions
afterwards otherwise whenever you're
ready
if you press the button in the middle so
it goes red it's over to you
um
good evening
the
main issue appears to be
the
declared need for such a property
uh property as
devised designed
seems to be appropriate there seems to
be no aesthetic objection there are no
major objections from members of the
village it's a neglected site a bit of
an eyesore right in the heart of the
village
and on that basis one would think it
would be plain sailing
however the need is governed by
the housing survey
carried out by the warwickshire rural
commission
in 2016 and incorporated into
warmington's parish plan in
2018
and
this appears to have ended up where it
has ended up as a possible requirement
for four bungalows
in fact historically
the uh
the origin of the need for such housing
in the village
uh is is somewhat suspect some of the
surveys carried out five seven eight
years ago
uh started from the fact that one
individual when filling in a
questionnaire said that they would like
to see one extra house in the village
for local residents to be able to
downsize to
and that's sort of gradually snowballed
into a need for
four bungalows
so
i think in a small community the actual
housing need
changes quite rapidly
and is a very personal thing depending
who's living there at the time and how
their circumstances change
and i don't think perhaps it should be
given quite the weight it has been
the only other objection that i can see
which is legitimate
is that the uh there is there are
parking problems in warmington always
have been i'm sure always will be
um
the
site at present has
two garages on it
and it has been commented by the
officers that these are not of a good
size for current modern vehicles
i think this is a very fair comment but
however if you look at the site plan of
the actual garages and the house there's
plenty of space for those two garages to
be actually upgraded to a modern size
and i would think that could be made a
condition of granting permission
and this is why we as a parish council
have recommended this and say there is
no negative action from parishioners
around about us
thank you perfect i was just about to
give you a 30 second warning but no need
well done thank you very much uh members
do you have any questions council crown
please
i think this is probably a fair comment
um
i mean i don't know what experience you
have of parish plans for little villages
uh it took us about 10 years basically
to get this made modified approved and
it was out of date a couple of years
before it was approved
basically and we're about to be asked i
think
in the next year to revise our parish
plan
and we view this with some trepidation
particularly of not being certain what
the government's current policy is on
whether parish plans will have any
meaning whatever
uh sorry
personal from the heart outburst but
now this is what
we'd like to see here from the heart and
but that's uh yeah i've suddenly got
your point from that one thank you
anyone else have a question
no
in that case thank you very much for
your contribution this evening if you
wouldn't mind giving the thing a quick
wipe down that would be great
while councillor hyatt is doing that i
will ask our next speaker mr tim
eastwood to make his way forward
feel free to sit this desk on the left
if you're on my left you're right if you
would prefer
so mr eastwood in the same way as
everyone else you'll have three minutes
30 second warning if you stay seated
afterwards for questions otherwise over
to you
um the main issue about my application
is this
requirement for a bungalow
um
there are
well firstly the site lends itself to
the
to the uh proposed development it fits
in nicely with existing
houses in the street and in the village
and done in nice haunted stone it looked
well
as regards the mobility issue
my mother who's 87 she has a stair lift
in our house and i know of three other
properties in warmington where all
people who have trouble walking they've
got stair lifts so
the requirement for a bungalow i i don't
really think that's apparent given now
these stairlifts work so well
um with regards to the site it did have
a house before that's on record at some
point a little bit a long time ago
um
the garage is
i'm quite happy to demolish the garages
if need be or extend them but i would
say that the highways don't like
the fact that you can't pull up
off the road open the garage and drive
in
if the the two standard sized doors were
removed and a single door was put in
there an automated door with a blipper
and the central column removed and the
outer columns which are horton stone
they're there and they're quite big for
visual appearance if they were removed
they were reduced the outers the outer
ones and the center one was removed you
could drive up
with a blipper the door would open and
you could drive in and i think there'd
be enough room created for two cars
quite nicely
um
my situation i've lived in this village
for 48 years
i'm a carer for my 87 year old mother i
have to make her meals for uh and make
sure this is okay day to day
i'm getting married next year
and
having this development would allow me a
decent standing living with my wife to
be and i'd be able to take care of my
mum
um
i'm grounded in this village and i want
to stay in this village i'd like to take
care of my mum
um
if i'm still alive when the house gets
sold
i'd like to make sure that it goes
somebody local
and also
relatively it's a small house and
relative to the other properties it
would be an affordable house for
somebody bearing in mind there's a
council house
up for sale recently
for 500 000
which you know puts me out of the up the
frame
that's about it really thank you
thank you very much indeed members do
you have any questions please counselor
adam
um can you just tell me have you
identified any other local residences
that might serve your purpose
well like i say the the there's a
council house for sale for 500 000 but
the
price is just out of my league
so that you feel that this would be your
only yeah it's not my only option yeah
without this um i'm i'm stuck and it's
it's going to reflect badly for my mum
and myself
thank you
do we have any other questions for mr
eastwood please
no in that case mystery would thank you
very much for contributing this evening
if you could press the middle button
perfect and then give it a wipe down
that'd be great thank you very much
while you are doing that i will call
forward cancer fielding again
as our final speak on this item
i think i'm becoming the cabaret
um that's the fielding you have five
minutes i'll give you a 30-second
warning um and if you stay seated for
questions that would be great otherwise
over to you as per usual um
taking the following extract from the
agenda and the officer's report
this application is seeking planning
commission for the development of a
single dwelling within the village of
warmington and
in accordance with policy cs 15 and 16
warmington is defined as an all other
settlement in all other settlement
policy as-10 part a
and cs
15-part g support small-scale housing
schemes
which
meet a need defined by the local
community
in the parish plan
but
part c of the development requires sdp
sdp goes into specific
details on local needs schemes
essentially they have the support of the
community which this does
they respond to identified need which
this has
be available to people with local
connections in the parish which this has
be a small scale within the within or
adjacent to the village
which this is
the applicant's site is encompassed
by re by residential development so the
applicant site is encompassed by
residential development and is
sited within the heart of the village
and i am therefore satisfied that
dwelling is contained within the
physical compounds confines of
warmington
can you put up the map showing the
street scene and the list of buildings
please
joe
map enlisted building
right you see where the site is that
house
nearest the the site
is where his mother lives
the application has been living in the
village for over 40 years he is his
mother's full-time carer he's proposing
to get married and move out of the
family home which is not suitable for a
married couple
the new house will be on the other side
of the street from his mother's house
the parish council
are prepared to support the scheme but
recognize the current housing needs
survey
must be updated which sarah brook taylor
has already told me
the housing needs survey recognizes the
need for four bungalows not houses but
none of the bunglers have been built
so and none are in the pipeline
i'm asking for an
exception with regards to this scheme
as his mother is in her 80s and is
starting to suffer from dementia he must
be on hand in case there's a problem
highways are concerned about
parking due to the sighting of the
garages
the applicant as he stated is happy
demolish the garage if necessary
if the committee is minded to grant the
scheme subject to the garages being
demolished
i would be grateful the garage would be
subject to a new application
this is a special needs scheme
for a long-term and respected member of
the community on a scrappy piece of land
in the center of the village
council thank you very much members do
you have any questions for our world
member please
no in that case council building thank
you very much if you could turn your
microphone off and watch the desk that
would be great
we'll move to questions for our officers
our points of call application sorry for
officers council mills first please
thanks richard um
joe this is
can you put a photograph of the garages
i mean i've i've seen the site but just
yeah um
and is that van
uh producing it protruding out onto the
highway at all
best way to show those in more
photographs
you can just see the pump there
right okay
right
so
we need
a new we have to provide two parking
spaces wouldn't be for this for this um
to me spd yeah we have to
okay
uh
that's all i need to know thanks thank
you any other questions for officers
council crump
just to follow up on that joe
so in your opinion the highways
opinion it's not providing the two
spaces as per the spd
fundamentally
apology
and being from highways is the impact on
the road network and highway safety
their own network in itself
[Music]
if it was granted could a condition be
put on that those garages were made
and suitable for the highways authority
a condition can be put on that the
garages are demolished
what i couldn't guarantee is it would be
suitable for the highways authority
because we would need a new application
to come into that assessment
okay thank you
okay do we have any other questions at
this point no in that case can we move
into the debate who would like to start
us off councillor dixon
thank you chairman
um i think this is one situation whereby
the officer has identified that
what is being proposed doesn't comply
with the parish plan the ndp etc because
it's not a bungalow it's a house
if the ndp had actually been drawn up as
saying we need some dwellings and that
would have covered all possibilities
so i think the parish council are
supporting this i am going to support
grant
because essentially i think it's a
situation whereby
uh in
those sorts of streets and lanes they
may be narrow but i don't see
traffic moving
rapidly through those streets at all um
parking is obviously a big issue in the
um the fact that uh this one might in
actual fact uh have
requirement for two parking spaces or
probably only one vehicle in truth um i
don't see it as an issue that should be
refused so in actual fact i would be
proposing that we uh actually grant this
application
okay thank you councillor dixon and
given you have made a form of proposal
to grant and we do have an objection
from the highways i'm just going to call
on our solicitors and make his comment
um about that
thank you jim and i do appreciate the
family concerns that have been stated
tonight
but as we have an objection from the
county council
um i have to refer you
to my previous advice to some counselors
who have been on committees before
that
any liability
that is basically the responsibility of
the county council if we go against that
objection
then that liability may pass to the
district council
so we have a duty of care to
the residents surrounding that
because of the issues highlighted by the
county council there is case law to
suggest that liability could pass
so i would be very careful in making the
decision
thank you very much and with that in
mind cancer dixon while we go around
everyone else if you could please have
us think about your reasons for going
against both the highways officer and
our own officer i'm not going to ask you
to do it now i am just have a think
about it for a moment
councilman mills next pleased thank you
chairman i mean it it is a
at the moment scrappy piece of land and
it
i know i think if however dwelling was
put on they'd be fine i think the
problem is these garages um
at the moment um i just wonder if the
it would need to come back would it for
another application um if we
so it would need to come up with another
application if
the applicant said yes okay i can set
the garages further back or we could
have a
a barn type garage which would be open i
mean you could just drive straight in i
mean
i agree with with mesa where you might
be on a bit of a sticky wicket with the
um
with the highways if an accident
happened and like council dickson said
you know they're not tearing through the
um the lanes is quite a narrow lane
my my concern with the suggestion now i
should reframe this like uh correctly
i sympathize with the um
the applicant's predicament entirely and
i completely understand what's been
brought forward
um
we have to make a decision on what's
been put in front of us
and what's been put in front of us does
include those garages and it does also
include an objection from the highways
authority from a highway safety
perspective so we have to be mindful of
that it is not within our gift to make a
material change to their planning
application we have heard that we can
put condition on to remove those garages
but that's the limit
um
i'm going to seek advice on whether if
we were to do that and remove the
garages would we still need to consult
the highways authority in order to
overcome their objection
so we would still need to have that so
that would regardless of whether we move
the garages that will remain unless we
go back to the highways authority so as
far as i'm concerned we would need to
either
um
[Music]
i don't
i really don't want to say the defense
defer which i don't think is the right
decision at this point um to get to get
a review from that or we would have to
get a new planning application in
and it's uncomfortable for me to sit
here and say that because i completely
understand the position that the
gentleman has been put into um but that
is planning law and we are here to make
decisions
in planning law yeah i think we're going
to stick you on here
um council crump next please
thank you mr chairman i've got the
utmost sympathy for for the applicant on
this one and i've been working with ryan
to try and support it is as much as i
can
um
again going back to consistency i've
touched on the spd for parking
uh with the two spaces and you're right
in saying that we have to make our
decision on what we've got in front of
us
and unfortunately there are too many
uncertainties on the the car parking
issue and the garages
so unfortunately i think the only way to
overcome that uncertainty is to refuse
and ask the applicant to come back with
a different application that covers
those issues regarding the parking
regarding the highways objection
and whether the parish council might
have amended their parish plan to go
from four
bungalows to
four properties that might be stretching
it but unfortunately i won't be
supporting this i'm very reluctant to do
that but unfortunately i can't and to be
consistent with my previous spirit in as
well
can i just confirm cancer trump is that
a former proposal to refuse
reluctantly thank you very much i'm i'm
again reluctantly going to second that
for the reasons i've already given does
anyone else want to speak at this point
no
um
we have had a proposal to grant from
councillor dixon i do need to seek
whether someone wants to second that
before we move to the second proposal
that has been seconded does anyone want
to second it
okay
okay because that was put first we do
have to hear that first so
we'll get the reasons afterwards because
i think i know which way this is going
to go um could it please have a show of
hands for those in favor of granting
[Music]
and those are games
and those against
so that five that does fail um
i didn't want to get your reasons first
because i think that was inevitable
sadly
um and for the interest in time i think
we're going to go to our next proposal
which is to refuse and loan the offer as
a recommendation go please have a show
of hands for those in favor of refusal
and those against
threats
so therefore committee resolves to
refuse application 2100 297 fu l
okay we will move to our next item we do
need to call in louise casey who is
who is our case officer for the next two
items and there she is
so next items are um application
four five very
and we're also going to hear at the same
time twenty one zero one three six two f
u l they are for the same piece of land
which has landed jason to 18 norton's
road bonfire hill in north end
while louise is setting herself up
members of the public just so you're
aware we do have strict time limits on
our committee meeting this evening one
of the reasons why i wanted to get
through the last one a little quicker
than uh we otherwise would have done is
because we are getting close to that we
have to have started our final
application by half past eight otherwise
it is going to be deferred until our
next item so i just want you to be aware
of that we will obviously make progress
through these this item now in in in
full uh
in fullness um
in the hope that we can get to that last
item but just be aware we may not get to
it
louise over to you
thank you chairman
so the site is situated um on the
southeast edge of the settlement of
north end
just to give you a bit of a background
planning permission was granted for the
erection of a dwelling on the site in
september 2019 condition one of the
planning permission required the
development to be carried out in
accordance with the submitted design and
access statement which subsequently
detailed the energy system within the
dwelling to be a ground source heat pump
an lpg tank has however been installed
at the property rather than the approved
ground source heat pump so the variation
of conditions application therefore
seeks to alter the wording of condition
one on the original planning permission
in order to change the approved energy
system to an lpg tank however given that
the tank was installed on land outside
of the approved residential cartilage
the development also requires a change
of use of land which the full plane
application is seeking to address
so this next slide here we can see the
two separate red line location plans
the land is not covered by any
particular land designation but is
positioned on the edge of the settlement
and here we've just got a google earth
aerial imagery just to demonstrate the
site context
you can see the dwelling just here
next we've got a plan to show the extent
of the area of land which is to change
in use um which you can see highlighted
here in red and the red circle on that
plan indicates the lid of the lpg tank
so
i'll show you some photos of the site
now uh yeah cool
i've highlighted the lpg tank here in
with a red circle you can see the land
rises up and the tank's been buried
underground we've got the dwelling here
in the foreground of the shot and then
in this next image we can actually see
what is essentially visible above ground
so it's just the lid uh there
so to conclude whilst the local plan
authority strongly encourages proposals
which incorporate renewable energy the
policies within the development plan and
adopted guidance do not reject proposals
which don't make use of this as such the
proposals are considered to be compliant
with the policies contained within the
course strategy and chairman it is
therefore recommended that planning
permission is granted on both
applications for the reason set out in
the report and there are no updates
louise thank you very much indeed our
first speaker on this item is councillor
james gordon [ __ ] now so if you could
make your way forward please thank you
very much
um i think you've got an idea of the
drill now three minutes 30 seconds
questions after whenever you're ready do
feel free to start
this dwelling was proposed to allow a
shepherd with local family connections
to return to the village
outline outline permission was granted
with an explicit condition regard
requiring energy from on-site renewable
sources to cover at least 10 percent of
co2 emissions
somehow the build was commenced with
just outline permission only seeking
full permission once the build was at
floor level with the footprint committed
the new design of the house was
significantly larger than the outline
planning and permission was refused
the applicant then attended our next
parish council meeting and spoke
candidly of the devastating financial
implications of being unable to continue
this very personal project
revised submission mitigating some of
the issues was made
and with the human face of the
implications very much in mind we
withdrew our objection
this new planning permission
strengthened the energy plans with a
design statement committing to a ground
source heating system compliance with
this design statement was made a
condition of the permission
the build was then rapidly progressed to
completion however somehow the whole
ground source heating system was
overlooked and an lpg system installed
instead
removal of this aspect of the scheme
with no other renewable energy solutions
or eco-friendly aspects to the build
other than cavity walls and loft
insulation leaves this property with no
better green credentials than a house
built 40 years ago
the property is now up for sale
the original purpose of the dwelling to
allow the return of the applicant's
family to the village has now vanished
along with the renewable energy
if the original application in 2013 had
presented a house of this scale with no
renewable energy no turning area
insufficient parking outside the village
boundary not being built for any local
need and with a core strategy in place
this proposal would never have been
given permission
i believe the planning officer is
mistaken in their approach when
renewable energy is made a condition of
permission we absolutely can and must
oblige them to comply
this development now breaches several
conditions of its permission only two
parking spaces not three no turning area
meaning dangerous reverse exits and no
renewable energy are none of these
conditions going to be enforced
two years ago this council declared a
climate emergency
you said you were taking this
declaration extremely seriously
here is an opportunity to prove that
wasn't green washing
the property is currently being marketed
for 650 000 pounds on a plot previously
owned by the applicant i'm sure there is
more than enough profit remaining in
this development to make good on this
critical obligation 30 seconds
if we allow conditions to be ignored
join the build and then retrospectively
remove because they are too expensive to
retrofit we render all conditional
permissions open to such abuse
there is little point us as volunteer
councillors giving up our evenings to
represent the local voice on planning
issues if the resulting commitments can
be ignored or circumvented later in the
process with no implications for the
developer
thank you
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for our counselor
casa mills
hi james hi um so
when the uh
original plan that was for ground souls
heating was it
for the
the original outline yes that just had
uh the condition of 10 percent renewable
right it was the retrospective
commission in 2019
that that had the ground source heating
as part of its design statement right
and now this this lpg
is
was put in erroneously i mean would it
just put him because i couldn't i
couldn't
say it's been put in as part of the
build
and the claim from uh the developer was
that the whole build was based on the uh
planning drawings rather than full
building
spec
uh whether that's true or not i can't
find it very hard to believe that they
would have built the whole house just
based on a on a couple of drawings for
the building uh for the planning
permission but that was that was the
line that was given
thanks james thank you that's the crumb
one question or one confirmation please
um how many
bedrooms are there in this property
please and did you say you've got two
parking spaces
uh there i think it's three
uh three bedrooms
and
there's
two parking spaces on the original on
the original plan the parking area is
larger than and they sort of cut
from one of your
one of your photos you could see that
the diagonal cut of the um
yeah that one
in the original plan much more of the
the gravel on the left hand side that
area was larger and and went further
across to the to the left
but that diagonal cut across with the
wall means a doubt you could get more
than two cars in and you certainly
couldn't turn them around to exit in a
forward gear like they're supposed to
thank you very much
okay unless there are no other questions
which there aren't counselor thank you
very much for your contribution thank
you
while you're cleaning the desk if you
could turn your microphone off that'd be
great um i will call forward miles
scofield who is our next speaker miles
if you'd like to make your way forward
good evening thank you very much for
your patience while you're sitting down
i'll just reaffirm three minutes 30
seconds stay seated for questions when
you're ready
um thank you i'd like to confirm my
objection to this variation um the
government set out a roadmap to reduce
the environmental impact on new builds
over 15 years ago i was involved in the
industry at the time the council's core
strategy states that mitigating adapting
to climate change is intrinsic and
include the use of low carbon
technologies i've watched this build go
up this build is a standard build and
through my observations i haven't seen
any elements um to reduce carbon
emissions but in fact there's a double
wood burner in there and now again a gas
heating system both of which will
provide
additional
um
uh emissions
um planning is approved based on the
implementation of just that one low
carbon technology the ground source heat
pump the application goes against this
goes against their own application and
the district policies and it's not
building for a low-carbon future
there's also a couple of bits of
information that i'd like you to make
i'd like to make you aware of
um
september 2020 i was informed in writing
that the builder had a full charge on
the diesel property and i believe at
that point it changed from an employee
building it on behalf of the owner to
having a financial interest
when the gas tank was going in i had a
conversation with staff on site outside
my property and i said to them
i quote i thought it was supposed to
have a ground source heat pump and the
reply was we were installing a gas
system as it's considerably cheaper than
the ground source heat pump and still
make meets sap regulations
in my opinion um someone with over 30
years experience would not have missed
that condition and i
my personal opinion is that i believe it
was a conscious decision
um it seems um but whether you believe
that or not if we put that aside and
this isn't a mix of technologies we're
not looking at moving one technology um
that we're looking at removing the only
technology low carbon technology on site
and as
it's already been stated
it goes against the counters core
strategy the planning conditions and the
environmental long-term impact here is
at play
um there's no solar there's no when
there's nothing else on site
um i'd like to put it to you that it's
it's not just more it's it's not morally
right and i'd like to be concerned that
this was set at president that it's okay
to just install um and have a um
disregard to the conditions on which air
condition
planning was was granted
um i'd like you to hold this developer
to account and request that you reject
this variation thank you
mr scofield thank you very much well
within your time members do we have any
questions for mr scofield
no in that case
thank you very much for your
contribution
and while you wipe that down if you
could turn your microphone off as well
for me uh we'll call forward carly
packman who is the applicant's is in
fact he's the applicant not the agent
can i do please come forward
now you have six minutes you can use as
much or as little as it of it as you
like um again i'll give you a thirty
second warning towards the end otherwise
it's over to you
really nervous sorry
so good afternoon my name is carly
pakman and i am here to represent my
husband and i and our business partner
construction
the parish council objection centers
around integrity and why we cannot fit
ground source heat pump retrospectively
and sustainability
with regards to the integrity my husband
has been building for 25 years and in
this time has developed
a reputation of honesty fairness and
transparency for his business and i am
sure that stratfor district council can
confirm
his integrity
in that he is someone that follows the
rules matt stanley and martin bennett
from stratford building control i know
would happily provide character
preferences
for his
workmanship
we took over this project from mr hayden
and his advisor sheldon and bosley who
supported mr hayden's property
in the handover we failed to notice the
ground source heat pump was specified in
the conditions
but this wasn't shown in any of the
plans that we've worked to
this was a mistake an oversight and
something we have acknowledged and we
really apologize for
there was never any attempt to a blo
oblige and
there was never any attempt
to avoid our obligations and i hope my
earlier comments
on
on this results
reassures you on
to this the parish council's submission
to the committee this is the first time
pacman construction
has sought to alter conditions
retrospectively
and we respect the parish council's role
but want to research reassure you that
there is
no intention to
subvert
the planning process
why we can't fit the ground source heat
pump
we specified the underground underfloor
heating
for a worcestershire gold boiler and the
supplier has confirmed
that the flooring
heating warranty would be void if we
were to use now an underground source
heat pump
we would have to pull up the floors and
the housing
and throw away all the existing pipes
pumps greed and much more if you were to
insist on a ground source heat pump
sustainability
i have a young daughter and i take
the need to reduce carbon footprint
extremely seriously
to make up for the lack of the ground
source heat pump we will commit to
planting additional trees and hedgerows
to more than offset the adverse of co2
impact from the gas boiler
i would also like to draw the count the
committee's attention to the fact the
parish council have recently installed a
new gas boiler to the village hall and i
would hope the additional trees and
hedgerows would
replant will also go some way to
offsetting this co2 impact from north
end
thank you very much for your time
ms pakman thank you very much well
within your six minutes um do we have
any questions from smackman council
dixon please
just one chairman um
do i conclude that you've actually taken
over the development and the
construction of this property from the
people who commenced the construction
um
the people that own the land still own
the land um they're farmers and i
originally come from a farming
background and we are
friends then if you like and and we've
taken it on now as a partnership to get
to get it completed
builder he was yes thank you
any other questions for mr patton
no in that case thank you very much for
your contribution
um counselor kettle had registered to
speak unfortunately um circumstances
outside of his control have meant he
cannot make it so he has passed me
something to read for you so i shall
read a verbatim now
obviously i can't answer questions uh
these two applications are being
considered tonight and effectively need
to be considered in conjunction with
each other
the first is the very condition one
approved plans to replace heating by
ground source heat pump with heating by
lpg stored in an underground tank and
the second is an application to install
an lpg underground tank in the
immediately adjacent field and for that
area of the field to be reclassified as
domestic garden land the area to be
reclassified is 3.5 square meters the
only visible part of the tank will be
the access lid
whilst it is regrettable given the
climate change crisis that the applicant
wishes to change from the ground source
heat pump to lpg
this i understand is not a reason in
planning policy to trigger a refusal as
under the existing core strategy the
council only encourages the adoption of
climate-friendly proposals and may not
demand them
there are therefore no planning reasons
for refusal of the variation of
condition one
with respect to the installation of the
tank
and for an area of agricultural land to
be reclassified i cannot see any reason
to refuse the installation of the tank
as it will effectively be invisible and
whilst i understand the parish council's
position and agree the loss of
agricultural land is regrettable i do
not consider the scale and of loss at
3.5 square meters in this proposal is a
material loss of agricultural land in
the parish
and as the tank will need to be
safeguarded the change in use of the
land being in the immediate vicinity of
the tank itself is not going to result
in an expansion of domestic
paraphernalia the reasons given above i
regret i cannot support the parish
council's position i therefore agree
with the officer's recommendation on
both applications
there we are that's councillor kettle's
uh submission we'll move to points of
clarification for our officers do we
have any questions for our officer on
either application
no in that case sorry councillor mills
yeah thank you thanks michelle um
can you
can you show me how far that is away
from the back of the house the is this
oh show me the lick that i can i think
you've got uh that's it
and that's all we can see is it from
okay
and but
as originally the um the application was
for ground source heating wasn't it
that's the original
when the foundations were put in that's
original
groundswell heat pump was included as
part of the proposal yeah it was
outlined in the design and access
statement only that came after
um so
from reasons you just heard from the
applicant they installed the lpg tank
and this is retrospective so they're
retrospectively seeking permission for
it now okay thank you very much thank
you
okay any other points clarification
no in that case we'll open up debate and
i'm going to kick it off um i'm going to
start so i i absolutely agree with what
council catalyst had to say i can see no
valid planning reasons to go against the
officer's recommendation whilst it is
regrettable and i find retrospective
planning applications enormously
frustrating we do have a framework for a
reason
we also have a framework that allows for
retrospective and that's what this is we
have to consider it under planning
policy and a planning policy i see no
reason to refuse so for application 21 0
0 3 4 5 very i propose with grant in up
in line with our officers recommendation
and for application 21 0 1 362 ful i
propose that we grant i am seeking a
second for the first please
on the very application
counselor dixon would you like to speak
to it
oh gentlemen i'm quite happy to simply
secondly
essentially
my own view is if this had come forward
with just the lpg initially we would
probably have been sanctioned
thank you very much and for the second
one which is for the full application i
also need a seconder for that cancer
family do i see a hand go up do you want
to speak to it
yeah i'll second this um as a member of
the climate change panel very
disappointing that
virtually everything's been disregarded
and this hash doesn't comply with any of
what we would if
an application for this house came in
now we would refuse this because there's
four or five items that uh that we would
require to be done so um they say
retrospective is a thing i really don't
like when things like this happen uh but
our second year is our second year
motion to go with it
thank you very much indeed unless anyone
has anything they pressingly want to say
counselor adam
[Music]
well
i completely agree with the parish
council's submission to the committee
and i think this is an appalling
approach to take frankly
i might not have massive material uh
planning um
reasons and i can understand where the
office is coming from i can't say in
good faith the planning authority
strongly encourages
renewable energy in the way that it says
in the in the report so i'm sorry i
completely disagree
and uh
[Music]
i don't know what else i can say sorry
would you like to make a counter
proposal
yes i propose that we
go against the officer's recommendation
and refuse the application
i mean there are
under climate changes and sustainable
construction
in the
report policies cs2 3
and spd parts are all cited there so i'm
sure we can find something so let's
start with that i'm going to assume that
proposal is for both applications
yes it is lovely thank you very much
council mills please thanks jim yeah i i
i think um
encountered james gordon coming and um
mark scofield they put up a pretty good
reason uh
for having this um refused uh
i think it made a pretty strong case
there um i agree with the councillor um
this adam that um
i would go against the office of
recommendation and support his um
proposal thank you that's just so
unclear that it's a formal second thing
oh yeah sorry yeah
okay lovely does anyone else have
anything they would like to add to the
debate at this point
no okay in that case we will move on
with a um with a vote so we have our
first proposal which is to grant in line
with officers recommendation we do again
have to take them individually so
looking at the very first application
twenty one zero zero three four five
very uh the proposal the initial
proposal is to grant in line with
officer officer's recommendation if i
could have a show of hands please
that's four chairman for those against
three german
abstentions
so therefore account uh committee
results to grant application twenty one
zero zero three four five vary we now
need to do the same for application
twenty one zero one three six two f u l
uh the proposal again in front of you is
to granting line with officers
recommendation could have a show of
hands for those in favor please
and those against
and abstentions
committee therefore resolves to grant
application 2101 362 ful thank you very
much indeed members we are just in time
to be able to in fact we have a few
minutes left over to hear application
2101 361 ful tonight our presenting
officer is once again louise casey
louise whenever you're ready over to you
thank you chairman so the application
now for members seeks planning
permission for the construction of one
four bed and one three bed local market
dwelling the application site comprises
land to the east of avendasset which is
classified as an all other settlement
so outlined here in red the site is
classified as agricultural land the site
is located within the ironstone hill
special landscape area the village
conservation area and the setting of a
number of listed buildings which you can
see here in red
so this slide just shows an aerial image
of the site to help demonstrate the
surrounding context again the site is
outlined here in red
and moving on to the plans this slide
shows the proposed site layout plan um
as you can see dwellings would be
arranged in a linear style pattern here
and here we've got some slight sections
at the top we've got a long sight
section which looks towards the
southwest side of the site and at the
bottom we've got a section which
demonstrates the relationship of plot
two with the listed building ave and
carro you can see here the difference in
land levels
next up we've got proposed plans and
elevations for plot one
and proposed plans and elevations of
plot two
so moving on to some images of the
application site this first image here
has been taken from hill view and looks
towards the application site in a south
easterly direction access drive is
shared they even carry the listed
building and we can see the existing
large metal barn on the application site
in the background in the photo here
and this next image shows the access
we're just moving further along the
access at this point um so you can see
the site uh here metal barn again and
then the access road is actually shared
the list of buildings this is where it
bends around and provides access into
avon caro
these next images here show the public
footpath which runs through the site uh
again you can see the large metal bar in
the left-hand image and the image on the
right here um we've got tree grove here
and even carry the listed building is
situated behind here
and again these are photos from the
public footpath looking towards avon
carro
so it just demonstrates the
intervisibility intervisibility between
the listed building the site
and then this image faces towards the
rear of the metal barn um
and then we've got a final image here
which has been taken from the access
drive vavenkaras this is actually
outside of the application site you've
got the north east elevation of avon
carry here on the left-hand side of the
image and then um
you can see that the the elevation here
so we've got the land bank where the
site where the land rises up and the
application site is situated behind here
so to conclude the proposal has been
found to cause harm to the conservation
area and the setting of the grade two
listed building known as avon carro no
public benefit has been identified that
is sufficient in outweighing this harm
in addition the proposal has been found
to cause harm to the character and
appearance of the wider landscape and
special landscape area so chairman is
therefore recommended that planning
permission is refused for the reason set
out in the report in terms of updates we
have had a
late response from county highways um
after our amendments were received and
consulted out to everyone but it makes
no further comment on the scheme and it
just reiterates that the previous
response and no objection subject to a
construction management plan
thank you louise thank you very much
indeed we'll move to our first speaker
on this item who is daryl muffett i'm
trevor gill from ivan dassett parish
council would you both like to make your
way forward
is it both of you or is it just one of
you
who who do we have the pleasure of
that do you mind if i call you daryl
uh good evening welcome um so i think
you know the drill three minutes 30
seconds and stay seated for uh questions
otherwise over to you
thank you
um
we have a parish plan in open docket uh
like many it's out of date 2007.
so in preparation for renewing the
parish plan
we had we commissioned a housing needs
survey
in 2019 and this clearly identifies the
need for uh additional housing and this
application meets
some of that need
uh we understand there was a site visit
earlier today
you will have seen that site is
something that i saw it's neglected and
it's decaying
and it's crying out for some sort of
development
the history of this application goes
back some time
when the applicants first submitted
their application the parish council
listened to residents and considered the
application on planning grounds
and indicated that we were going to
object
the applicants listened to us who
withdrew their application
then we considered their position
and uh they they replanned their
application
taking into account
objections from planning from residents
and from the parish council all the time
on planning considerations
the applicants sought expert opinions
the commission reports and made
evidence-based decisions
they changed their application and
reduced their application from three
dwellings to two
in terms of the current application the
parish council sought views of residents
and the applicants and facilitated
question and answer sessions we weren't
allowed to hold meetings
due to covert
following this we consider the
applicant's response to the planning
considerations and agreed to support the
application but with conditions
the objection from the planning office
has surfaced towards the end of the
planning process
not at the start and not during so it's
a bit of a surprise as it seems so
fundamental
to talk about the linear housing
development there are plenty examples in
ivan dassett of non-linear housing
development and residential built areas
again there are examples and maybe you
saw those on the site visit
so to us the applicants have
based their application on evidence and
we struggle to see that evidence coming
through from the planning officer
so in summary we see the application
meets a need the site is in bad badly
needed development and the applicants
have been responsive to constructive
criticism from the planning authority
from residents in the parish council
they've backed it up with expert opinion
and reports
we made our own suggestion to support on
the basis of conditions which was laid
out in our response
and we see the recommendation for
refusal being based on a generalist
opinion not specialist uh advice based
on fact
thank you
that is absolutely spot on three minutes
so thank you very much members do we
have any questions please yes please
cancel dixon just one chairman uh
councillor moffitt um
the
report indicates that even that's linear
form not many buildings behind etcetera
obviously your housing assessment needs
survey
uh it shows that there is a need for
housing
do you with your experience and
knowledge of the of the parish in the
under village um
nowhere
sites within the linear form which could
be developed get bearing in mind this
one's right on the edge
and it's behind
and are we talking about the only site
that's likely to be available
um it's very difficult to see sites
coming up on the on the linear form
um most of the village uh appears quite
full
uh i think for in my opinion
uh it's difficult to see how anything
could be developed without going
backwards without going into the uh
into the
unbuilt landscape
david thank you casa crump
again
yeah i was i was on the side visit today
and then drove through very slowly yeah
through through the village
i think i was overtaken by a tractor i
was going that slowly
um but yeah it was um
interesting to see um
um when you do get suddenly a different
perspective with the side vision i
certainly think it was well worth
undertaking
um my question really is
was the parish council unanimous in
their support of this
application uh the parish council was
not unanimous
i think we are five members and the vote
went four to one okay thank you
anyone else have any questions
no in that case thank you very much for
your contribution this evening
and thank you for your patience as well
thank you
okay our next speaker then is mr tony
island
speaking on behalf of the residents if
you would like to make your way forward
i'm sorry you have six minutes
is that right yeah
you have six minutes i'll give you a 30
second warning use as much or as little
as that six minutes as you like
um and then if you stay seated for
questions afterwards that'll be great
whenever you're ready it's over to you
um i don't know if i should make this
clear or not it's irrelevant but i
perhaps should tell you is that i'm
actually a counsellor at oxford county
and cherbourg district and i say that
for no other reason that
i'd like to be open
okay thank you very much um
i have i have written down here what i
was going to say but having listened to
what has been said i think i'm going to
have to uh jump in and speak about
different topics for instance the topic
which hit me straight away was the claim
from the parish council that they've
been talking to people i can assure you
i've not met one single person in the
village who can actually say they've
been asked anything by the council so i
don't know
how they did it but it's certainly a
mystery to me
i was asked by the
residents and i'm one of them of avon
carrow to represent them
and they have a unanimous view
on this totally unanimous and including
along in that
are the owners of the cottages which uh
front on to this development which you
saw in the in the drawing
sorry in the picture um
so
i find it quite difficult to believe
that the proposed two houses fit fit a
good criteria so this got me rushing for
my
copy of develop requirements
supplementary planning document and
in there i found a couple of paragraphs
which i think are relevant and what the
first one is
design should have a positive response
to the local character its history and
identity
now i really find it very difficult to
accept that the proposed housing that's
going in there which is
modern what i call executive homes
cookie cutter uh is what the
we need in they even decide we don't
need that they even tacit
what we need is genuinely uh affordable
homes for the local people
um
and i also came across the uh pro
proposals to erect a new building must
not
adversely affect appearance or setting
of the listed building well
if you can see if we can go back to one
you can see that the building itself is
a fine gothic victorian building it's
quite unique it's been one of the best
kept conditions authentic
around
so i don't quite see how the development
of these cookie cutter homes
which probably no local could afford
fits in with the look
of that building
as you've shown that um
there is a road which
starts off with in the village
with
um
little cottages either to the right of
it and cottages to the left of it
very attractive you then have the road
which comes into haven carrow
as you walk into the site
it goes up
and it levels off at about three meters
three and a half two and a half meters
around is various it's an uneven
plot
so if you're stood on the road
at the level of avon carrow
you have a
a mound of about three meters and at
that level then the houses will be
proposed will be built onto it so you're
looking at uh
the height to be equal
to the existing tower so you see that
you can see the tower there
nope there's a stain there for a second
back to the front one
that's it
you can see that the height of the of
the uh the tower there very clearly and
if we go now to the
courtyard
yep
that's that's the other side of the town
now if you look across you can see that
the buildings directly at the end there
are very small one and a half height
buildings
and now if you
if you can imagine if you can
project your gaze from the top of that
building
across into the trees beyond
that is the height of the proposed
houses that are going in they are
just about the same height as the
existing tower
and will certainly loom over
us
we have the
courtyard okay um okay we have the old
old picture
if you know that
that's that's an old aerial view of
even uh cairo and you can see that the
land surrounding it is agricultural
uh the development going on here will be
mostly on agricultural land it's not
part of the the village
it is on agricultural land and you can
clearly see that
moving on
so
i think the question is who wants these
houses
well i can tell you
um
and of course
back to the spd 30 seconds thank you spd
clearly states that new houses must have
the support must have the support of the
community and this must be evidence
based now the only evidence we have are
those people that responded to the uh
council this council and they had 20 i
believe 24
comments which were accepted
22
were against
one was not sure and one from another
developer was for it
thank you chairman all i ask from the
councillors is to follow your own rules
and regulations that we all have listen
to your own planning officer who's done
a fantastic job i have to say very
detailed and who has recommended refusal
or more importantly listen to the
villagers of avon dassett and refuse
this application thank you very much for
your time mr ryan thank you very much
for that members do we have any
questions for mr violet please counselor
crump first
you're you're a councillor you say
they're elected at uh the district and
the county and town anton
holden triple hatta absolutely i used to
be can we get to the point please
counselor
in a minute yeah i'm excited
i might as well get to the question and
do it properly um
i don't reckon that the tank at the
paris council
they are elected representatives of the
community i assume they had an election
and instead of four it was
uncontested
so
how were they not representing the
community compared to you as a town
district and county council well i think
you just have to
you just have to look at the number of
people that contacted this council the
only one that's the only indication that
a true indication that could be verified
that we have
and those you can see the 24 people and
23 objected one was wavering saying oh
it's a bit nice if we had a few more
trees etcetera and one was totally
uh for it and as i said that is no
surprise to any of us massive came from
another local builder developer no
surprise whatsoever that's the only rule
that we have we don't think we can look
at i can tell you that everybody where i
live or all 17 dwellings
are against it
but you only have my word for that the
only thing we can look at are the
numbers of people that contacted this
council and put their points of view and
were accepted and you can find them on
the website which i'm sure you've
[Music]
do we already any other questions for mr
please
no in that case mr wright thank you very
much for your contribution and thank you
again for your patience
while you wipe that desk down for us i
will call forward our next speaker is
jane cashmore
who's hopefully here i don't see
i wonder richard hardy as well forgive
me i didn't i didn't read line two
while we're waiting um january is it
yourself that's going to be speaking or
is it mr harley
okay who's starting
would you like me to give you a 30
second warning before the two minutes is
up or should we just say there's two
minutes
it's time to go
yep no problem at all um in that case
when you're seated
um
while i tell you what while you're i
haven't got that in front of me if you
want to take a seat at the front here um
and we'll just double check that uh
on the on our systems um and we'll
listen to you guys speak anywhere in the
front there doesn't really matter
okay over to you when you're ready
thank you
i'm a historic buildings expert for
cotswold archaeology i'm a masters in
historic conservation and have years of
experience undertaking heritage
assessments
the site is generally not appreciable
from within the conservation area only
the western extent is visible from hill
view where the gable of the dutch barn
can be seen
the current barn is identified in the
conservation area appraisal as a
negative building
slide two please
the orange arrows represent examples of
existing buildings and streets that
branch off hill view and have set a
precedent for the settlement pattern as
such the principle of development behind
the properties on hill view is already
well established
consequently the proposed development
would not represent a meaningful
diversion from this character
a landscape and settings expert from
aspects has concluded the proposed
development will have a positive impact
on the special landscape area and
conservation area does not conflict with
the existing settlement pattern or
encroach on the agricultural landscape
there is existing built form on the site
so it's not a so it is not an open site
as stated in the reason for refusal to
hence there is no conflict with policies
cs5 9 and 12.
in terms of the setting of avon carro
the building's principal facade with its
central tower faces southwest
overlooking former gardens from where
you get the best appreciation of the
significance of the listed building and
from where the proposed development
would not be visible
the embankment of the north east
boundary with the site has historically
been populated with trees that have
acted as a screen between the listed
building and farmland beyond this
creates a sense of enclosure in
segregation from the landscape to the
north as does the ground level changes
the proposed development will have a
positive impact on the conservation area
through the removal of a negative
building negative buildings and
introduce residential development that
is appreciably set back and separated
from maven cairo the proximity of the
development to avon carry won't detract
from the important elements of the
setting of the listed buildings and
hence no harm will occur
slide three please
if you disagree with our heritage expert
and consider less than substantial harm
would arise i now set out six public
benefits which in my professional
opinion outweigh any harm
firstly two local market homes are
proposed this is a social benefit i know
none of the local market needs in the
housing needs survey have been provided
to date
secondly heritage benefit the removal of
negative buildings from the conservation
area and replacement with two
well-designed dwellings will be
beneficial
thirdly visual benefit aspect landscape
planning identify the visual baseline
comprises an area of degraded land and a
collection of poor quality buildings
aspect includes the proposed development
delivers a significant benefit to the
special landscape area and conservation
area
fourthly the public right of way will be
significantly improved fifthly the
inclusion of renewables and lastly the
environmental benefits of net
biodiversity gain thank you for
listening
thank you very much both 10 seconds
short of your time so well done thank
you
members do we have any questions please
council mills
thank you good evening um
you say it has a positive
setting on the area uh can you expand on
that how
it is positive
on a
conservation area is it are we in a
conservation area here
yeah can you tell me how that's positive
and conservation area um so we consider
it an enhancement to the current
baseline of the conservation area so the
removal of the negative buildings and
the
uh the improvement of the site itself
with the consolidation of the
existing trees
and the design of the houses themselves
also
mirror the materials and form of
existing buildings within the
conservation area
so the
sorry mr um
uh
what is the problem what is the material
proposed for these um
jane yeah
so
in materials um it would be natural
slate roofing local stone walling timber
frame windows with stone dressings
and in terms of that visual baseline as
richard says the building which you're
looking at on the left is identified in
in the conservation era appraisal as a
negative building in an unattractive
building so that baseline is of a low
position which would be enhanced
thanks jane thank you
council crumb please
is your microphone on there
thank you um
the object to mention the loss of
agricultural land
how much would be lost and what grade of
that land is it please
sorry
yeah um i'm going to ask the planning
officer for the site area please i don't
know that um and
in terms of the grade of agricultural
land i i don't know i don't know if the
applicant is we can probably address
that with the questions to our officers
in just a moment if that's right cancer
crime and we'll get the answer then
it's easier to do it then um do we have
any other questions
no in that case all three of you thank
you for your patience thank you for your
contributions
while you guys wipe down the desk um we
will call forward our final speaker of
the evening who is councillor fielding
you know the drill five minutes 30
seconds stay asked for questions
afterwards it's open and ready for you
to go when you're ready if i can ask the
uh planning officer to show me where
hill view is i would like that please
before i start
further over further north
i'm showing where hill view is now with
the
red dot you can see it's the main road
that runs through the village
the act
sorry
uh thank you chair before i start i'd
like to clarify certain matters the
applicant's age and notified
the planning officer about my distant
relationship
the deputy pla monitoring officer in his
response to her stated that the
relationship was too distant
i am supporting
this application as the ward member
i am open-minded to this application
over the course of many of my time as a
counselor i've argued that agricultural
buildings should be treated in the same
way as a brownfield site
again i'm happy to state that i'm
open-minded
the need for this development has been
accepted by sdc's planning policy
under scs-15
and as10
cs 15
distribution of development part g
deals with local needs schemes on a
scale
community led this
scheme conforms to the local needs
survey
cs810a
sorry community small scale schemes for
housing developments
for develop sorry housing developments
for employment or community facilities
to meet a need identified by the local
community
this is the
redevelopment of redundant farm yard
not only are some of these buildings in
a dangerous and hazardous state there
are hidden
there are hidden hazards within the
undergrowth
they house vermin this is also
a liable liability on the owner and if
any and the general public
um
are injured while trespassing off the
footpath they are responsible
now taking the planning officers
comments in order they are set out in
the conclusion
cs5 deals with the landscape regarding
the distinctiveness and historical
character and the visual impact which
depends on the scale and use of the
location
it also encompasses
trees and woodlands within the strategy
there are no plans to remove trees that
are healthy
the proposal is to enhance the screening
between the carro
and hill view and the development i
notice that the picture showed
from the the site were taken in winter
and therefore the
bushes were down the carousel
so the car sits well below the site and
is currently well screened by bushes and
trees which will hide the development i
do not understand the comments
concerning opening up this area to
enhance the green field aspect
the only way this can be done is by
cutting the trees down
and this will have a detrimental effect
on the stability of the bank
cs8 i do not agree with the argument of
the planning officer that this would
affect the historical element of the
carrot and hill view
the
embankment along the north and south
sides of the site could you put a
picture of that which i can show
which we didn't get a chance to look at
when we were on site no the other side
the other side of the barns
these are any photos that i have i don't
have anything
your time is still ticking yeah i know
on the north side there is a high bank
um which will screen
the
trees and will hide the development the
linear aspect of the village has changed
with time there are at least five coral
sacks along the main street
cs9 deals with the design and the
distinctiveness the owners have looked
at this element within the policy
attracting the sensitivity and
distinctiveness
and the environment sustainability
everything has been considered to meet
these requirements and the water storage
and other facilities
which meet sdc's environmental
requirements
cs12 landscape the aonb and the einstein
hills
the principle of these areas is to
improve the view therefore by removing
the buildings you will improve that view
in both the as both the parish council
myself have supported this application i
would be interested to know why the
officer believes there is less than
substantial harm in this application and
what does this happen what is the green
field aspect
that
has been raised by the officer the other
thing i'd like to dispute is the
unanimous
matter with from the caro i know of at
least one member of the carro who is
against it and is supportive of this
scheme and i believe there are others
that's very thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for
cancer filming
no in that case concerning thank you
very much contribution if you give the
desk a quick wipe down before you leave
that would be great
okay let's move to points of
clarification for our officers we do
have one outstanding from cancer comp
earlier on have you had an opportunity
to pull that detail up
yeah
so um
the plan helpfully outlines that it's
3271 meters squared the site um in terms
of the agricultural land classification
i don't have that to hand unfortunately
one other
really quick question at bottom page 94
you say
acknowledge that the development
introduced two local market dwellings
in including short-term economic
benefits during the construction period
and support for local services
can you explain why
there would only be short-term economic
benefits i can understand during the
construction period but
surely those houses are going to be
there
for a
longer than the short term so therefore
there'll be some economic benefit of
supporting local services
yeah the short term economic benefit
just references obviously during the
construction period um in terms of
economic
any economic benefit beyond that i've
not been able to identify any obviously
there is the benefit of the fact that
they are local needs dwellings and they
have been identified within the housing
needs survey
very brief but won't those two houses
potentially be supporting local services
by the indiana villages like supporting
the the poor et cetera
yeah so that that again is a benefit
yeah so yeah
future occupiers you know will will
contribute to using the services with
the village that's right yeah yeah fine
thank you
any other questions casa melz thank you
um
are we are we within the coastline
survey of the carrow
no we're not right um and we are in a
conservation area just to confirm that
yes
right thank you
anyone else with a question have
questions um i've got one of my mae
louise um uh mr eyla loses the fact that
the these dwelling is going to be taller
than the tower on the other side of the
cairo is that correct and if so by how
much
so i mean it's a difficult one to answer
because i i don't know how tall the
actual uh the the part of avon carry
building is i
if i go back to um
his slides
just bear with me
so yeah you can see in the background
there is obviously the the one and a
half story element that's quite low and
then beyond that that's where the houses
will be i can tell you that
the difference in land levels between
um
where even cara is positioned and where
the site will be there's three meters
and then the houses will be around seven
meters tall so
we use that to try and work out how tall
they will be i don't know how tall that
part of the building is of the listed
building okay thank you you had a moment
ago you had on your slides uh an image i
think it was a side view across section
view um that showed the proposed and
then the land levels up to ivan carroll
if you could just bring that up again
for me please
that one um
can you zoom into that bottom section
for me
please
i can bring the plan up so that'll be a
bit
better
just bear with me yeah no problem
got to find it
the the one you had a moment ago it will
suffice for my purposes
if you don't mind
if we can just sort of zoom into that
bottom bit and that gives me a
reasonable understanding
that's great
we're on a joy with tech today aren't we
there's a little gray box just on the
top right hand corner if you could just
bring it down a bit so i can see it
that's perfect that's what i wanted to
see lovely thank you very much um unless
there are any other questions um from
points for qualification to our officers
uh then we'll move into debate
who would like to kick us off
go on
sorry councilman mills
it's a bit more peace please yeah i know
it's nine o'clock
cracking on is it um
i do have a little concern for this uh
of
the impact i mean this is um a caro i
mean it's got uh
historic
connections for the country of them
our chairman didn't realize at the
beginning since i told him about it but
um
uh i'm just worried about the impact it
has on the carro
and
and what the
president said about the um
the height of the buildings you know
looking over the carrot itself and when
the trees
and they shed their leaves that would be
more visible
so i've got a bit of concern on that mr
chairman thank you
thank you casa mills cancer dixon
thank you chairman uh obviously the
benefited from the site visit uh today
and were able to not only walk the site
but also walk on the side of the caro
and look up and i walked up to the uh
the car parking area at the back there
which was probably the highest part of
their ground level etc and obviously
into the courtyard
my own
view was that very much that
at the ground level
in the courtyard
those trees would be hiding
the proposed dwellings
i fully acknowledge that from the first
floor level looking across uh especially
in winter you may be able to see the
properties if we were minded to grant
them
obviously the recommendation
from the officer is to refuse
uh on the grounds that
it's there's insufficient benefit public
benefit
but
i see
the provision of
housing for locals as being a benefit
sufficient to outweigh the
minor uh
problems with uh with the application
and i do not see
any
detrimental impact upon the listed
building
it is well screened at the present time
vegetation will
enhance that screening
and although
this may be agricultural land it is a
land of very limited value from what i
could see when i was on the site
thank you very much council dixon um
just once clarified was that a form of
proposal to grant
yes jim thank you very much um does
anyone else like to speak at this point
cancer crump
i think on on balance i'll be happy to
um second cancer dickson's proposal
and i could come up with some reasons
should he get that far we will need to
do that if you could both think about
your reasons for a moment while i seek
if anyone else has anything they would
like to add to the debate at this point
no
while you'll continue to think about
your reasons i am going to ask our
solicitors come in on a point of
clarification are in terms of the local
needs housing
thank you chair just to clarify um i
know everybody refers to local needs
but
when this is marketed
basically um the local need
period is only 12 weeks
and if a local person does not purchase
or
somehow transact or contract with the
actual seller
then the seller after 12 weeks can sell
to whoever they want to and then that
next person who comes in to buy the
property will have to go through the
same 12-week period so it's offered to
locals but then again if no local takes
that up it could be sold to anybody
in the world
so
i just had to
clarify the definition of local needs
yes it is offered to locals they get the
first buys but after 12 weeks if there's
no transaction then they can sell to
anybody in the world
thank you thank you for that
clarification um so i'm now going to
come back to unless anyone else wants to
make a comment cancer adam
just uh broadly speaking i mean we've
had a range of local views from there
and those are the types of views i
normally try and take on board most
um the ones that stuck with me the were
the ones that stuck with the officer's
recommendation
um and and that's kind of the way i'm is
it on the balance but that's generally
the way i'm sort of going so just for
the sake of balance i think i'll propose
that we go along with the officer's
recommendation
very good thank you very much uh we will
take a second there for that in a moment
if anyone wants to second that but while
we do i'm going to come back to cancer
dixon and cancer crump for their
reasoning to go against officers
recommendation please
come in here in the on page 96 the
officers report overall i'm a view that
the proposed development will be
conflict with the existing established
settlement pattern and that it would
encroach upon the surrounding
agricultural landscape
um yes it's right on the edge of the of
the settlement and therefore one would
say it probably does encroach but i
would not say does it is in conflict
with the established uh settlement
pattern and therefore i would disagree
with that uh comment
and therefore from that point of view
the proposal does not conflict with that
when it comes to
[Music]
the
local needs listening to to mesa
certainly a situation whereby
local needs have been identified by the
parish parish are supportive of this
application
and
although 12 weeks is a limited
period of time if there's somebody in
the community who is actually in need of
such a dwelling as identified in a
housing needs survey then 12 weeks is
sufficient for them to say i'm
interested
so from that point of view i think we
can basically say that i would disagree
with the balance being given by the
officers
thank you dixon and cancer crump please
yeah so the other added benefits are
removing negative
buildings from the conservation area
visual
benefits improvement to the public right
to why renewables
net by
net biodiversity and potential economic
benefit
would these benefits are considered to
be sufficient to outweigh the identified
harm caused to the designated heritage
asset
okay thank you very much um i'm going to
look for our officers now and see if
they could very quickly summarize uh
what you have both just said our reasons
thank you chairman yes i've just made
some notes along the lines that uh
councillor dixon and councillor crump
have indicated so councillor dixon
indicated that he felt uh the proposal
wasn't in conflict with the established
settlement pattern
and he also felt that in relation to
local needs
um
that
essentially a 12-week period was was
adequate for the purposes uh of
of of that and he felt that if there was
somebody
local who was uh uh ready to go as it
were in the purchase that they felt they
would be able to do so within that
12-week period um councillor crump added
to that that he
i think acknowledged the uh
the heritage uh issues but he felt there
were some benefits that outweighed those
namely uh removing um the the barn as it
currently stands in terms of its visual
appearance
the economic benefit that the occupiers
may
deliver
in terms of using local services and
also issues such as biodiversity
net gain and he felt on balance that
those benefits um outweighed the
identified heritage harm
are you both satisfied with that
um cal state i think you said earlier
about
the trees being sufficient to shield
from view
and therefore protect the conservation
area do you want to add that in
i thought you might
i was listening
okay good um so we have our reasons um
would anyone else like to contribute
towards the debate we do have a proposal
waiting to be seconded should anyone
wish to but if they don't we will move
to a
uh a vote
councilwoman
[Music]
i'd like to second councillor adam's
proposal
um
the reason being that there are 20 plus
objections i don't know how big the
little hamlet is but 20 is a lot from
what i can see
today so i think there's sufficient uh i
think it's sufficient against this to
for me to second counter adam's proposal
okay that would go along with the
officer
thank you very much indeed
council dixon
i would only make a comment if i may
chairman
um that
we heard that 17 people who are
residences of the cairo are amongst the
objectors that's all
okay thank you very much um we do need
to consider conditions and s106 um could
our officers give us an idea of
conditions s106 should this be granted
please
yep i've got a list of conditions
um should my recommendation be
overturned so obviously
it would be subject to a section 106
legal agreement to secure the properties
as local market dwellings then in terms
of conditions we've got standard three a
time limit in accordance with the proof
plans submission of material samples
hard soft landscaping scheme and then in
conjunction with that retention and
replacement planting scheme land
contamination and remediation conditions
six and seven um condition eight
development to be carried out in
accordance with the recommendations of
the protected species survey condition
nine um a biodiversity management plan
to be submitted in order to detail the
measures to both enhance the site
initially and in its long-term
management
then condition 10 development to be
carried out in accordance with the um
updated arboricultural report condition
11 submission of foul and surface water
drainage scheme 12 um
in order to ensure the recorded
alignment of the public footpath is
marked out within the site condition 13
no site security fencing to be erected
within one metre of the public footpath
14 a construction management plan 15
bins to be provided 16 electric vehicle
charging points and condition 17 water
butts
and then we'd request also that the word
and of the notes on the application are
delegated to officers if that's okay
that's absolutely fine as far as i'm
concerned are you both happy with that
are there any conditions you want to add
thank you very much cancer cramp you
happy a thumbs up is fine
top man
least enthusiastic thumbs up i've seen
for a while as well okay so we have a
proposal to grant application twenty one
zero one three six one f you off the
reasons given and with the conditions
that we've just heard could we please
have a show of hands for those in favor
of granting this application
and those against
five in that case that
that resolution has failed we do have a
proposal to refuse in line with officers
recommendation that has been seconded uh
if we could please have a show of hands
for those in favor of refusal
sex german against
in that case committee resolves to
refuse application 21-0-1-361-f-u-l
land at buildings at cairo barn in avon
dassett
members thank you very much tonight i
don't we have no urgent business no i
know asian business
thank you so much thank you for your
patience particularly for members of the
public for their patience and we will
see you in two weeks time
thank you
you